so we got this journalist an
investigative reporter who says that
based on Russian flight information from
from State air travel it appears that
Russia's nuclear High command which is
Vladimir Putin and two other individuals
are currently holed up in nuclear
bunkers and the general idea is that
they've just now fled to these places
around the same time we're getting
reports that Putin is pulling back
troops from Kiev of course ask the
simple question why would Vladimir Putin
and their nuclear High command go to
nuclear bonkers
and then pull their troops back well a
lot of people immediately say looks like
they're getting ready for some kind of
bomb but the reality is there have been
reports that Vladimir Putin may have
already been in the bunker we know that
the two other members of the the nuclear
chain of command in Russia have already
been missing for a couple of weeks
likely insecure locations so I wouldn't
look too much into this in fact the
story might might actually be that Putin
is pulling things back in general
however Russia did State the spokesman
for the Kremlin that if they felt they
were their existence was threatened they
would absolutely use nuclear weapons
which is not surprising so we're going
to talk about that and then we got it we
have a lot of other stories to talk
about but we're gonna have a really
interesting show because obviously with
this is it's it's the midterms elections
seemingly substantially more important
these days I guess to most people
because the culture war is so hot and a
lot of people are concerned a lot of
Democrats are concerned they're not
going to win Republicans have a general
ballot advantage and one of the big
issues that I constantly bring up is all
of the lies over the past 10 years all
of these stories that have been put up
by the mainstream media that have just
turned out to be false one of these
stories which was
um I could go through the list for you
again but one I typically don't mention
but was was the story of Brianna Taylor
the media story on this one the
narrative was just not true so joining
us is one of the officers from the
incident Sergeant John Mattingly uh do
you want to introduce yourself yeah I'm
uh John Mattingly I was a sergeant on
the Louisville Metro Police I was there
for 21 years uh retired in May of last
year
and so now I've got a book coming out
and just going around telling people
about it 12 seconds in the dark trying
to get some truth out that's right so
you are uh you're the officer who got
shot correct that was that was the story
and so uh the media lied about
everything oh yeah yeah there's not much
truth to it yeah yeah and there's I
think there's a there's a really
interesting conversation here that
people probably won't expect because you
know the activist narrative is that you
guys or just police in general are evil
and and single-minded but uh I think
we'll have an interesting conversation
about policing what happened what are
people's rights you know how you view it
plus a lot of stuff people probably
don't even know about what really went
down that night exactly there's plenty
of guys on my own Department that even
though they went through a year of riots
didn't even know the the story behind it
they didn't know the back story so so
we'll get in all that and uh we also got
Sheamus yeah I'm Sheamus I run a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we upload
political cartoons every single Thursday
sometimes on Tuesday we got one coming
out this Thursday on transports and the
sort of like milk most conservative ink
response we hear often times and I think
you guys will really enjoy it very cool
I am also here in the corner pushing
buttons as I always am happy see Sheamus
we don't have Ian tonight unfortunately
he is traveling back to be here with us
again tomorrow but he's not here tonight
so bear with us we'll get him back
shortly oh Ian he's abandoned us yeah
but uh no I had a sub in for him last
night and I was gonna try to do my best
Ian impression but I figured we should
get you a wig yeah exactly but uh Ian
might actually walk in the door I told
him I was like if you get back whatever
just walk in and said I hope he does I
like to meet him yeah yeah well I think
he'll be here no matter what but
hopefully he comes in anyway so uh
however before we get started why don't
you guys go to timcast.com become
members to help support the work we're
doing as a member you'll get access to
exclusive episodes of this podcast
they've got Monday through Thursday at
11 PM just about and uh we will have one
of those for you tonight and as a member
you're making sure our journalists can
keep working you can see right here on
the front page we have an on the ground
reporter at a South Carolina Trump rally
because I think one of the things we
definitely want to be doing is not just
field reporting but actually we want to
do many documentaries and and full
feature length documentaries so we're
working on all of that stuff with your
support as members we can make it all
happen so don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends let's
uh let's get started with this first
segment
ah CNBC with appears to be some good
news Russia repositions troops away from
Kiev marking a shift in the war well
this sounds this sounds good I mean the
troops are going to be moving away from
Kiev it sounds like Vladimir Putin is is
gearing up to to pull back maybe even
Retreat and
retreats to a high uh Retreat as high
command into nuclear nuclear bunkers
okay that being the case it now kind of
reframes the retreat into is Vladimir
Putin pulling his troops out of Kiev
because he's going to drop a bombs on
Kiev
is that a stretch no clue absolutely no
clue but I agree with you that it
definitely changes the tone of the story
to hear that he was going into a nuclear
bunker rather than just pulling out I I
do have to wonder though if this is just
tabloid click bait yeah yeah I mean
after what I've been through the last
couple years I don't believe much of
what the media says so it's uh I think
it could be if he's in hiding it could
be because they've got inside
information that maybe his own people
are going to take him out because
they're tired of losing family and
friends in this useless War but it's
even that true yeah who knows this is
the crazy thing about the about the war
is that for obvious reasons you have all
of these Outlets reporting that uh you
know Putin's fled to a bunker they're
citing this journal journalist Christo
grossov who has links to British
investigative outlet bellingcat but it's
too juiciest story for any of these
Outlets to pass up right they absolutely
have to and you know my issue with how
all of these articles frame is look I
think we should talk about it I think if
there's a possibility an investigative
reporter is saying hey this may be the
case probably a good thing people know
because while we're probably not going
to see nukes dropped anywhere you just
you know you don't want to imagine
imagine you do get someone who's ready
to fire nukes and some story happens
that indicates it might happen and they
don't tell you you we we you better know
but uh I I'd appreciated these out these
articles would start by saying it's a
single investigative journalist looking
at flight paths from government you know
planes well when was this put out it
starts today and it's uh about Metro oh
no it's everything I mean everyone's
picked it up okay so so they're all
citing this one guy from he's gonna say
if nobody else is talking about it then
it's probably true yeah because it's
it's you know they don't they don't care
about it yeah yeah I wonder if uh you
know we've seen all this media saying
Putin's losing they're like he's
retreating he's losing it's not going
well we constantly hear these stories
about how his generals are dying and I
just don't know whether whether to
believe any of it no I mean so I was
talking about this with Alex on the
Green Room uh or in the green room
yesterday and people have been talking a
lot about Russian information we
shouldn't believe anything we hear about
the war that comes from the Russian
government and fair enough I have no
reason to trust them but also I have
reasons to actively distrust my own
government and the industrial you know
military media complex that our own
country has and so we're almost in the
dark who is it I think it was Mark Twain
who said it's better to be uninformed
than misinformed something along those
lines it's just every single time con I
consume news media I almost feel like
I'm getting Dumber yeah
so I do want to make sure we point out
uh we have a story from Times of Israel
zielinski says he's willing to make
concessions to achieve peace without
delay which includes a compromise on the
donbass region so this is yesterday it's
entirely possible what's really
happening is Vladimir Putin's already
been in a secure location they're
pulling the troops back because they've
won
is this is what Vladimir Putin wanted
the Eastern region of Ukraine so no
nuclear war what do we do afterwards do
we do we just say Okay Putin's label to
keep taking these territories and just
oh I hear you I mean I'll I'll borrow a
point from you here Tim
and paraphrase you a bit uh I am not
going to get my foreign policy wisdom
from the people who believe jussie
Smollett
and who you believe man yeah the people
who believe the Covington kids yeah I'm
sorry who did not believe the Covington
kids got that one wrong who's gotten
every single story wrong who are you
supposed to believe when we're talking
about war yeah I think I think social
media has become I mean this is the
first world we're fighting with active
lives Social Media stuff so we're
getting a totally different take
and a different spin than we're used to
and so I think maybe
some of the things are going to be good
kind of like during the the protests in
2020 we had the live streamers out there
and if we didn't have them we wouldn't
have really known what was going on
because the stuff you got were mostly
peaceful you know whether the fires
burning the building behind them and I
think this Pro hopefully that's going to
be the same thing that happens here
we'll get some on the ground legit
people that are are part of it that can
actually give us some of the truth yeah
I mean
it sounds a little bit cheesy right
because we hear people in the media
using this as a talking point all the
time but it is really important for
people to be able to trust their media
unfortunately we're really not able to
there's just no media apparatus we can
count on to reliably tell us the truth
and so they're constantly bellowing
about the fact that no one trusts them
and they're constantly saying if we
really want to have a functioning
Society there needs to be some common
narrative People Unite on and No One
Believes us but then they never take
responsibility for lying and it's kind
of funny it would almost be as if you
were constantly cheating on your wife
and when she didn't trust you when you
you know told her you were just at work
late your response was you know well a
household can't function if you don't
trust your spouse okay well there's a
reason it's true we do need to be able
to have people in these positions who we
can trust but we're just not able to and
I think we've gotten so cynical on media
over the past couple years and I've
basically been cynical on media my
entire life that you you lose sight of
the fact that we've it's really very sad
that there aren't people we can like
genuinely count on to give us the truth
here I don't know if there ever was
truth I I will I would agree and that's
the thing I I would also agree that
oftentimes we we have a lot we have our
Nostalgia goggles on right we look at
the past and say that's when the media
was honest but we know that isn't true
like the New York Times covered up the
Hall of War there's there's a lot to dig
into with the fact that our media was
basically always dishonest and so I'm
glad that's being exposed
I really am but it just makes you sad
that people don't have sources they can
trust and I think part of it is because
of how gigantic these Outlets have
become if you have more local politics
being discussed by people and folks on
the ground who live in the communities
that they're discussing about cover the
issues I think you get more reliable
information but when you have CNN trying
to report on everything that happens in
the country it's just all the
information is ripe to be manipulated by
them well and you've also got what four
major companies that control all the
media Outlets so there's something like
that there's a monopoly on it and
they're all kind of slanted the same way
and they're all money driven so once
you're money driven the truth's out the
window it's going to make me the most
money today yeah absolutely I feel
really bad about this because I'm
blanking on his name we had him on very
great guest he talked about the Loudoun
County
um assault case
he he was the journalist who exposed it
oh Luke rosiak yes okay thank you one
thing he said that I thought was really
instructive was he as a local decided
that he was just going to pay attention
to an issue which was near to him and so
he called the father who was being
maligned in the media and asked him why
he responded the way he did and the
father explained that his daughter was
sexually assaulted that's the kind of
Journalism we need but it's no
coincidence that it was a person who was
a member of that Community who actually
got that information it's it's getting
to the point where I don't I I don't
think I can trust media sources that
were not there on the scene or aren't
part of the community I don't know
because they have and also they have no
incentive not to lie about what happened
there it's not their Community well take
a look at this right so we have the
story Times of Israel says Ukraine could
declare neutrality offer security
guarantees to Russia and potentially
accept a compromise in the contested
area in the country's East to secure
peace without delay hinting at possible
concessions uh yo this this sounds
basically like defeat like Russia's won
the president of Ukraine says says we're
going to give you what you want
now they've been reporting over and over
again that Russia was losing they showed
these videos over and over again of
Russian tanks being hit and Russians
being ambushed they lie about you know
these tanks running people over all just
insane propaganda I you know I'd ask
people do you think Vladimir Putin is
intentionally targeting civilians and
they would say yes and I'd say why would
you think that like I don't think
Putin's a good guy but we're not like
human beings are not Comics book
villains well he's not dumb he knows if
he does that then they go in and take
over Ukraine and they occupy it he's not
going to have their loyalty because but
they're family members I should clarify
too what I mean is there are people who
believe that Vladimir Putin is killing
civilians for the sake of killing
civilians he is he his his invasion is
killing civilians in the name of his
military objectives but I'm specific
what I specifically mean is like do you
think he was like hey go in there and
kill civilians well of course not he's
saying go in there and just do what you
have to do regardless of the concert no
I mean when when our government kills
civilians it's collateral damage and
that's just the cost of Waging War but
of course whenever when other
governments do it it's because they
intentionally want to kill honestly
people yes but I do got a pause there
and give issue a slight correction under
the Obama Administration we did
something a bit more clever when when
the United States killed civilians in
the Middle East we just said are they
adult men and they're enemy combatants
if they were if they were combat aged
males military age men they would not be
classified as civilian deaths that
slipped past me I didn't know that talk
about that's horrible dirty dirty stuff
and that's what's fascinating is that
whether it was Trump or just this
emergent phenomenon you end up with a
lot of regular Americans uh populist
conservative types just finally coming
out being like hey we don't want any of
that we don't we don't we don't want
military aged males just being bombed
and then you guys just pass the buck
Donald Trump runs as a republican saying
bring our troops back the war makes no
sense and people are clapping and
cheering for them Joe Biden
you know I love how the Democrats can
keep pushing these lies about we don't
want war and then what do you get you
get chaos you get more war okay isn't it
so crazy under Donald Trump no new Wars
certainly wars were being were still
being fought yeah he was far from
perfect on foreign policy Joe Biden gets
in and how long until we got a new war
well to be fair Russia's invasion of
Ukraine is different from a U.S Invasion
somewhere yeah but there's there's
Global instability we've got reports of
true U.S troop movements in Syria and
this is almost immediately so it's not
surprising Korea shooting there or China
whichever one's shooting the missiles
back in North Korea yeah North Korea
yeah I mean look under under Donald
Trump we had we had security issues we
had we had concerns you had North Korea
doing their nuclear tests
but I think the reason Vladimir Putin
didn't invade Ukraine is because Donald
Trump crushed Isis and then pulled our
troops out and Russia was like all right
and Russia went over there and get their
tail kicked out yeah in the Middle East
I mean they didn't fare very well when
they went over there they thought they
were going to go over and just do what
they do and they didn't and you talked
about the propaganda uh zielinski was it
yesterday or the day before so I think
was yesterday said they're going to
start having back putting kids back in
school
yeah wow and I thought
now is are they really going to go back
to school or is he going to say they are
and then blow up one of his own schools
with nobody in it and say we had these
casualties to make it look like Rush is
the super enemy again I don't know I
just I'd like to I want to see in the
next week or two if one of their schools
happens to get bombed and then you'll
know it's it kind of laid the ground for
this the the challenge with false Flags
is that
it's always a simpler solution that an
enemy bombed their enemy
but we do know that countries and
governments use false Flags like the U.S
and the Gulf of Tonkin or the proposals
around operation Northwoods once that's
right yeah so it's tough zielinski's
lied already several times when he was
like oh no they're bombing the nuclear
facility quick NATO no-fly zone and then
they're like there's radiation no and
then you know the international times
generals it was like four three years
ago was it really yeah it was like 2018.
so there's a video that uh this is the
remarkable thing people are like
it looks like a green screen and then
you actually see people online banking
it's not a green screen it's just it's
just because they front like they do a
bunch of lighting so it makes it look
like like the back isn't you know
properly connected you can see his
shadow and I'm like
the image behind him is a still image
the trees aren't moving there's no
movement no wind nothing you trees move
yeah and it's just uh whatever man I
don't know I just what I do know is they
lie everybody lies no yeah absolutely
and it's so bizarre how people are
willing to be completely cynical about
their own political leaders until
Warfare breaks out and then every single
thing they say is Gospel truth and if
you if you doubt what they're telling
you you're siding With the Enemy it's
ridiculous yeah now you're they don't
become good people put an apologists
yeah no I'm not I'm just calling both
sides they're both dirty exactly like
the people who have consistently lied to
us for their entire time on the public
stage didn't miraculously become honest
human beings because a conflict broke
out on the international stage yeah
we got this story here let's pull this
one up from the from the New York Post
this is just it's just frustrating
Hunter Biden laptop material entered
into Congressional Record hey that's
really really good they say material uh
uh from Hunter Biden's Infamous laptop
was entered in the Congressional Record
at the request of Matt Gates the Florida
Republican made the move during a
hearing on oversight of the FBI cyber
division after its assistant director
Brian
vordren testified that he didn't have
any information about the hunter Biden
laptop which the bureau sees from a
Delaware repair shop in 2019 a house
Judiciary chairman Jerry Nadler
initially blocked Gates's request but
relented a short time later nadler's
change of heart came after what Gates
described as consultation with majority
staff
I seek unanimous consent to enter into
the record of this committee content
from files from and copies from the
hunter Biden laptop Nadler responded
without objection
there's a lot of really nasty stuff in
there but the craziest thing is some of
these emails directly implicate Joe
Biden in his scandal involving Ukraine
and kickbacks dirty dealing
well in all of the same people who told
you that this was a baseless conspiracy
theory expect you to trust them on
Russia and Ukraine yeah
two years later and say oh never mind it
was real yeah it was exactly yeah no
it's real now even then they won't say
it would like they almost try to do this
funny thing whether it's like it's real
now it's real now but like back then it
wasn't when you were talking about it it
wasn't true now it is you know the
stories where they claimed the laptop
was Russian information they're still up
really yeah they're not corrected their
opinion piece is masquerading as fact
it's so paranoid how do we break people
out of these this these lies these
manipulations how do you expose people
to the truth and show them the
corruption if well I think if somebody
wants to believe that they're just going
to the the topic of Russian
disinformation is so hysterical given
that this is a concept which was
lampooned for decades as soon as the
Cold War ended and even during the Cold
War there was always a very
tongue-in-cheek attitude that the
American Press and American Media took
towards any suspicion of Russia but then
as soon as they decided that you should
think Russia is a real threat millions
of people started thinking Russia is a
real threat even though weeks ago they
had been making fun of people for even
considering the possibility that Russia
was a negative actor on the world stage
or that we should be frightened by them
so I mean if you're able to do that kind
of a 180 because the media told you to
I'm not really sure what I can say to
you to convince you otherwise Russia is
a threat to I mean to to uh Western
dominance and sure I'm level domination
well sure I'm not saying that these
other countries uh in other major
players on the world stage are not
adversarial to us in any way but my
point is it was considered laughable to
say anything negative about Russia
remember in 2012 when when Mitt Romney
said that Russia was going to be a large
geopolitical Foe for us and he was
laughed at by everyone in media and then
in in 2016 we go not only not it's not
as if they started taking this realistic
approach of saying well Russia is a
decently sized Nation there are world
power maybe we should be concerned about
them it turned into everything that goes
wrong in our country is because of
Russia which is insanely paranoid in a
complete 180. and it's just another
buzzword I mean yeah like like you know
white supremacist racist homophobe you
know it's whatever it's whatever that
that's gonna stick that that Rouse
people up enough in their emotions that
they don't care what the truth is I feel
this certain way so I'm gonna I'm gonna
express myself and believe you and
attack the other person who doesn't
agree with me it was a breath of fresh
air when the when the biggest viral the
viral story of the day was that Will
Smith smacked Chris Rock up yes because
I'm just like good distraction it but
it's a good distraction but uh kind of
you know literally a good one because
like can we just back away real quick
from being at each other's throats all
the time and just argue about WWE on on
the Oscar night yeah I mean I think my
instinct and the Instinct of a lot of
people when that first happened was to
say that this is a distraction there's
something important going on that they
don't want us to see but then you dig a
little deeper and you go what are they
distracting me from something else they
were just gonna lie to me about anyway
and I wouldn't have gotten the truth on
yeah I think I'm getting jaded I don't
know everybody you know when it comes to
arguing about Chris Rock and Will Smith
it's kind of just it's relatively
nonsensical
when it comes to arguing about what's
going on the war there is a good you
know a a good point in that we need we
need to know exactly what's going on
with with legitimate information to
prevent catastrophe
but for the time being you know or I
should say in this current time
people will just believe whatever
they're told to believe yeah people on
the left are like the media can lie to
me a million one times and I will still
believe whatever they say well because
they're not going to the media to get
actual facts they're going to the media
to watch the media forward a particular
narrative and so if they get information
wrong it's actually inconsequential
because they're still doing their job
which is telling me things that make me
feel like I'm a good and virtuous person
for supporting left-wing causes it kind
of goes back to the I mean they've
almost got the abusive relationship
syndrome yeah where you know you're
going to beat me down but then you're
going to apologize and I'll accept it
and then you're going to do it again and
but you're never going to do it again
but then you do it again but I love you
and I'm afraid nobody's better than me
if I don't just keep coming back for you
I hear you but it's it's but it's worse
than that because there's never an
apology dude I'd like flowers every once
in a while you know what I mean I should
have gotten I want chocolates after
Russia game at least when the Deep State
tried to depose a democratically elected
president no nothing just story blew
over I wonder if there's like a a funny
bit on business models that operate the
same way they consistently don't do
their job but keep apologizing and you
keep hiring your toilet breaks right so
you hire a plumber and he walks in and
he's like all right let me get to it
eight hours later he's like all right
well I'm leaving that'll be you know 500
bucks and then look and there's just
crap everywhere they have those it's
called hedge funds yeah yeah yeah just
keep doing it and it's also uh it's also
very true of political leaders you see
this all the time whenever someone's
running for reelection they go the
country still has all of these problems
I didn't fix it in the first two years
or four years give me another four years
seven years yeah give me more time to
not do the thing that I was supposed to
already have done if any other industry
operated the way the media does just
think about calling your you know hiring
groundskeepers to like mow your lawn and
they leave and send you an invoice and
you walk outside and they didn't mow
your lawn you'd be like okay well they
didn't they didn't or Worse still they
mowed we they mowed it all awfully and
then they mow your neighbors and you're
like okay like hey you guys made a huge
mistake and they go no we didn't they
call you they're like like actually that
is you're like hey you guys messed my
lunch like that's Russian disinformation
let me send you a snorps article we
actually did a great job mowing your
lawn just against the skags mower I used
exactly but it's funny that we tolerate
this yeah this is supposed to be one of
the most vital services for for a
country and it's just broken I gotta say
though I think we're tolerating it less
more people are paying attention to it
but what's being done about it yeah I
think people are just not paying us you
know what it is all right we're about to
go a little bit so you mentioned abusive
relationships and I want to take a
little bit further on that uh analogy
because when you are dealing with
someone who is truly toxic one of the
best things you can do is just stop
paying attention to them you're probably
never going to hold them accountable
you're never going to get them to admit
they were wrong you just have to remove
them from your life and I think that's
what a lot of people are doing with
mainstream media
yeah it's about time I suppose because
no other industry gets like fails at
their job this miserably well I guess
government I was getting ready to say
yeah it's pretty uh they've set the tone
yeah
yeah what what will wake people up what
will get people to to finally because
I've asked everybody this nothing people
do not get involved in anything in life
until it affects them personally
yeah for the most part that's just the
way it is if we can just go about our
business and just pretend it's not there
put my head in the sand I'll just keep
going on but once like once I was
affected by it personally I took it more
serious and then I I was encouraged to
reach out to people and go whoa they're
lying hey pay attention but before then
I knew they lied but it was like it's
not affecting me so I mean it is but
it's not you know not personally on a
personal hard for hardcore right to the
Bone level and once it does that it's
kind of like drinking and driving it
doesn't bother you if somebody you know
gets killed by a drunk driver yeah and
then you're like oh man that's horrible
or overdose you know my my cousin died
of a of a fentanyl overdose and it's
like took a little blue pill that she
thought was a muscle relaxer that
somebody gave her and wow I'm sorry so
what did it turn out to be fentanyl oh
yeah yeah yeah you just said that so you
know and and while you put the good
fight out for it it's still not as
personal until it affects you and then
you know you just feel a little
different yeah I mean So speaking of
which I I didn't pay a whole lot of
attention to the uh the Brianna Taylor
case I'm not sure when we wanted to get
into that in your story and what you
feel we got it we got about we're
getting there because okay all right
yeah well then on the thread that we
were just on
your question is what can we do to get
people to wake up to this stuff make
funny cartoons I think making funny
cartoons is one thing but here's the
thing everyone in this room anyone doing
anything politically related for a
career talking about that stuff is
completely useless and their job doesn't
have a point if if our audiences aren't
standing up for these values in their
everyday life so one thing that's been
said in this show before by you I
believe and it's something maybe I was a
little too cynical to accept at the time
but I would more or less agree with now
is that with with most people who buy to
the narrative if you were to sit down
and have a half hour long conversation
even a 10-minute long conversation with
them about a lot of these issues they
would come away with a different
perspective not the people who are
ideologically possessed but just your
average person who believes in this
stuff and so the solution is just for
the people who are watching the show and
who believe in what's being said here to
be more willing to have conversations
with people around them and I know it's
frightening I know a lot of people are
scared to do it but there is never going
to be any significant change in unless
that occurs because we're just talking
to you and it's funny because audiences
will look to their preferred political
commentators to talk about this stuff
and what you don't realize is like we
are looking at you guys to talk about
this stuff it's very it's a very it's a
two-way street yeah everybody yeah
exactly it can't just be us talking
about this it can't just be us having
this or these conversations you got to
bring this stuff up around people you
know who can be persuaded I'm tired of
hearing about secret Trump supporters
you know the secret Trump vote I'm like
why was it a secret why didn't you tell
anybody the only reason anybody had
anything to fear if they were a trump
supporter is because Trump supporters
wouldn't speak up exactly no you had a
mix though some Trump supporters
wouldn't shut up about it right line
Flags everywhere in their trucks and
stuff I can respect that I think a lot
of people are like I better not say
anything it's like just say it because
if everybody did you'd be fine yeah well
and we're scared it's exactly everything
it's it's amazing how scared this
country has gotten just I mean on every
level and I don't know if that's been
the course over the years of you know I
remember back in uh probably 2010 we
were in a big meeting at work and
um one of the higher-ups was talking he
was like well you know perception is
reality we can't do that and I was like
oh ho ho ho ho perception is not reality
reality is reality amen and I get what
you're saying you got to be careful how
you frame stuff but it doesn't matter
what this guy thinks of perception if if
Tim thinks if his perception is
different than 50 people but we're
worried about his perception so we're
not given the truth then we're hurting
the other 50 people just to please the
one and it's just well that's what's
true it just kept going and going and
now we're we're where we're at we're so
politically correct Everybody's scared
to tell the truth nobody has thick skin
where they can take the truth yeah and
so we just shut up and and then the loud
ones run the country when people say
perception is reality there's there's a
good point being made right I understand
that you know what you what what you see
kind of dick dictates what you focus on
and how you live your life but uh the
problem with the problem we have with
journalists is that they've taken that
to heart and instead of saying I should
seek other perspectives to fill out the
narrative they say if I say it's true
because perception is reality and my
perception is all that matters so
instead of doing any research and
telling the truth or just like what I
think goes I think both of you made
points about the most vocal people
representing the movement and yeah
that's very much a consequence of your
average person who exists within any of
these movements or leans towards those
movements being way too afraid to say
anything and so unless you want your
movement to be painted exclusively by
the folks who are willing to talk you
have to stand up and say something and
that's the point I really want to stress
for everyone I know I say it pretty
often on these shows but if you guys
aren't out there talking about this
stuff there's no point for us to be
doing this I want to just jump straight
into this next story because uh this is
about Brandon Taylor's mother she's made
with doj and demanding federal charges
against the officers in the round of
tailor at death so this took place in
2020. the story is significant for a few
reasons one it plays Into the Heart of
what I've been saying over the past
several weeks specifically Trayvon
Martin's story was fake the Michael
Brown story was fake the George Floyd
story was heavily lied about the Ahmed
Arbury story heavily lied about all
these stories I said they're fake I'll
clarify they were all extreme
exaggerations and manipulations by the
media to the point where in the in the
George Zimmerman incident with Trayvon
Martin they edited the Audio I think it
was NBC NBC News yeah they edited the
audio to make it sound like he was
racist they cut out key context they've
done this for basically every single
major story that's resulted in Black
lives matter riots and then we try and
get the real story if you're able to get
it to like all of a sudden you go wow
now the interesting thing here is
Republicans have a a general polling
Advantage from Real Clear Politics about
3.4 points and with 530 about 2.2 points
when Democrats have a five-point
advantage or less they lose seats in the
House Republicans have a have an
advantage which is to suggest that
people aren't falling for these stories
anymore here's where it gets crazy so
we're sitting here with John Mattingly
you were there you were involved in the
whole incident and the media and the
activists are still lying about what
happened trying to put pressure on the
government to make changes and to get
certain politicians elected right so
we'll we'll start here like what's this
story about now we can go back and you
can we can get into the the details yeah
so this was just a couple weeks ago
um they went to DC her and Ben Crump the
clown yeah that runs around and
destroying cities and takes his money
and jets he's a lawyer right yeah yeah
which I guess
together I don't know how he's a lawyer
but you know he just mumbles and jumbles
when he talks
um so they went there and they met with
the doj and the funny thing is you know
during all this I requested meetings
with the FBI then I wouldn't talk to me
uh they've met with him several times
and I'm thinking well how are you only
talking to one side that doesn't make
sense to me but anyway that's that's a
whole other thing so she went there and
they talked about uh you know what's
going on the case when are you going to
do something when are you going to do
something and the very next day uh Katie
Cruz was indicted by the feds or two
days later it's a day or two later and
who is Katie Cruz so Katie Cruz so the
day when when all these riots started
the first night in Louisville there were
seven people shot in the the very first
night of riots downtown boom boom boom
people were being just crazy
and so the next night
um you know the police presence was
still there it was still heavy things
were still out of control the crowd had
moved from downtown because they were
blocking streets off and stuff to more
toward the west end of Louisville and
we're at 26th and Broadway there's a
little store there that it's called
dinos and it's always been a super
problem area shootings robberies drug
activity just it's just out of control
area so however
these people were no longer rioting
because they were in their neighborhood
it was basically a huge block party I
mean the people were shooting guns they
were doing illegal stuff but they
weren't causing destruction like
downtown they weren't you know doing the
the things that would require police
presence to be forceful and so
our department decided that they were
going to send officers down there to
clear it out they were breaking the
curfew that was enacted by the mayor
um which I don't agree with those either
but so when they sent him down there to
enforce this curfew and make all these
people leave this lot
um
there was some activity going on I think
there were some gunshots right down the
block and two other Crews from what I've
heard had turned down the request by the
chief's office wow go down there and
take it they went by looked they said
too dangerous out of control I'm not
putting my guys in that that situation
okay so they called another one nope not
putting my guys in that situation they
called the third group he sent their
people down there with the National
Guard
so
Katie
following commands they're like all
right if they won't disperse shoot some
pepper balls that'll put the the OC in
the air and it'll it'll irritate people
enough while they go inside
she fired some pepper balls at that time
uh one of the business owners that owned
a barbecue shop right across the street
from that gas station comes out and
shoots a gun at him whoa so the national
guard fired back and killed it right I
remember the story yeah and so just a
couple weeks ago she was indicted on
civil rights violation for shooting a
pepper ball whoa because they said her
shooting the pepper ball
caused him to think he was getting shot
at and he fired back now how they can
know from a dead man what his thoughts
were
you know shooting back at him pepper
balls do not sound like guns no no
anybody's gone to a paintball range and
has ever gone to a gun range knows come
on and you know that guy had video in
his in his business kind of like you
have here you know cameras all over so
he had some great angles and you could
see everything that happened and our
mayor would not release that until the
media found out there was good video and
pressured him and then he released it
because everything they do is just just
such he comes out and says oh we are
very uh transparent transparency is the
way to be which it should be you should
be very transparent if you're if you're
operating on the government's dime and
they're paying you there should be no
stone uncovered everything should be
wide open if you are a cop
these that right now I'm telling you
you're going to prison yeah it's like
it's no good they're hunting they're
headhunting yeah yeah look we've seen
all of these riots
summer is around the corner summer is
when riots pick up I'm not entirely
convinced it'll be nearly as bad as 2020
a lot of people were like they were
angry for a lot of reasons you know
kovid locked them down people were on
edge we may see things get pretty crazy
especially considering it's an election
year we got the midterms coming up and
it's going to be serious if Democrats
lose the house
it's going to be something crazy yeah so
so I'll tell you see the all the all the
cops out there you they're going to get
called out yeah they're going to get
called out to a riot and they're going
to be and they're going to get be given
a reasonable order as it pertains to a
violent ride of people smashing windows
and burning things down
something will happen you'll go to
prison and here's the Catch-22 in that
I've sworn an oath to protect and serve
and
as a citizen I'm looking at the police
going why are you not acting when
they're burning our stuff down why are
we you know now they're being told by
command they do they follow orders
unfortunately sometimes that's good
sometime that's bad but they're
following orders and they're told to
stand down and a lot of them are looking
at it now what you just said Tim they're
going if I act I'm going to prison screw
that that building ain't worth me going
to prison good so so they're staying
them down so now you the the citizens
are mad at you because you're letting
stuff burn
the the government's match if you do act
or they come at you so it's a no Winston
too bad for the citizens too bad for the
too bad for the civilians who wouldn't
say hey maybe it's reasonable that we
have a police force that's going to stop
people burning buildings down if they
won't stand up for the cops that are
going out just trying to stop rioting
well then you deserve what you get and
that's cops being like look if you don't
got my back I don't got yours I can't
yeah City you get I think it's really I
think it's unbelievably horrific for a
police officer to fail to do their duty
to fail to protect the people that
they're supposed to protect at the same
time if you're a citizen and you're
lamenting this ask yourself the question
if one of these police officers acted in
a way which was justified to protect
somebody else's livelihood and prevent
their business from being burned down
and then they were placed on trial and
the media was calling them a terrible
racist would you say anything would you
say anything to the people at work who
were calling that man a racist for
trying to protect people probably not I
mean statistically probably not so it's
not just that police officers aren't
doing their jobs they certainly aren't
but nobody is no one's standing up for
the things they're supposed to stand up
for no one is standing up for civility
this country is falling apart man well
it's like we're here yeah our viewers
are here we're we're a community of
people who care there are a lot of
people in this country who care but
there's too many people even who do who
they care about what's going on are
unwilling to speak up
you know I from personal experience I
can tell you we've reached out to a lot
of people if you're willing to have me
on other people are but there's a lot of
people who still do not want to attach
my name to anything you name them do you
want to name them you want to call
anybody out no you don't have to no no
here's what I'll call out so I'm
supposed to We were supposed to go speak
in Ohio I won't give you the city but
we're supposed to go speak in Ohio on in
April and they were going to use a
training facility of this Police
Department
and the police department was still
charging them they would charge them to
use their facility
and
once they put the flower out and it
showed my picture on it the chief of
that department said no you're not using
our training facility he's not welcome
here for just a training it was it's a
support thing for spouses
who go through critical incidents and
they and and and this group that was
bringing us in is huge on bringing the
community and the police together to try
to to try to merge them you know you
know what I think is that uh we often
talk about the problems of policing you
know I've certainly complained about the
cops who are enforcing covid lockdowns
but but it's not it's it's not a police
problem like this but particular
instance when a cop when this cop
arrests the salon owner like yeah that
was a cop problem the problem is just
cultural and moral decay in the United
States extends beyond the population and
into police departments so what happens
is you'll get a dude who's uh he works
maybe at a um an insurance company and
they're doing a bunch of or how about
this he works at a Home Depot and then
Home Depot comes out and says everybody
you got to do the woke stuff I think
this was in Canada they did this and
that guy says I'm not going to say
anything because my my protecting myself
and my assets is more important I don't
want my family to be sick or starve I
can certainly understand that but what
that means is that the cultural and
moral connections of our society are
gone granted that happened in Canada but
just an example if you work for a
company and you won't speak up that for
that same reason neither will
firefighters neither will police neither
will politicians not nobody would that
kind of goes back to your point what you
made a few minutes ago where it's our
job to protect the city but you said you
can understand why they wouldn't
but well this is right I understand but
at what point do you go okay no matter
what My Sacrifice is I'm willing to go
out there because I want change now this
is exactly my point that when regular
people aren't showing up to city
meetings being like look we understand
police reform can be done and there are
problems people are upset about but at
the very least stopping a riot should
not be questionable but they don't do it
these people are going to be like I'm
not going to say anything because then
they'll come in right at my house and
and okay well then the cops aren't going
to do anything and you know what's worse
the cops are going to show up to your
house when you're the victim and arrest
you you see that guy in Wisconsin
guy was in his house BLM showed up the
mccloskeys no no no in Wisconsin a guy
was in his house BLM showed up to his
house protesting the same organizer
organized a previous protest and that
set fire to another house
so this guy brandished as a shotgun
through his window as one should I mean
if people are going to potentially burn
your house down that's not enough I'm
not giving people advice and saying you
should do that I don't think he should
have done this you don't think nobody
was going to point a gun at them but I
think to let people know that you're
okay well then no Miranda Shane was he's
he pointed the shotgun towards the
window at the crowd yeah no then you
should have died you should not holding
it up I'd be like fine whatever but
either way you're in your own house yes
I I have questions about first of all I
can say don't Point your weapon to
someone else ever ever ever unless you
intend to use it that being said if
you're on your own property
and you're and you're holding your
weapon you know
there's questions there but ultimately
the real issue is the cops showed up
went to his house and arrested him to
Cheers from black lives matter yeah they
cheered the same group that wants to
abolish the police was cheering when the
police did did what they wanted they'll
go into your house and arrest you the
mccloskeys are a good example though
they broke on a private property
destroyed the fence the mccloskeys came
out armed on their own property
she was dangerous with it she didn't
know what she was doing but she did
point out you can see her point at least
one guy okay and people thought this
guy's boom mic on his camera was a gun
but hold on there a minute a guy was
holding a black object with a boom mic
yeah sure in hindsight you can tell it's
not a gun did she know that no the
adrenaline's flowing right you got I
mean even young people even train people
that's tough in that quick of a second
to distinguish but somebody that's not
trained coming out with that adrenaline
dump and the fear I mean your rationale
it just goes away a little bit Yeah well
I mean also you have to consider if
you're in your house and you're with
your family and there are people outside
of your who as you mentioned it burned
down a house previously it's it's again
you should never ever point a gun at
people if you're not willing to use it
but um for for people to know that you
have some ability to protect yourself is
obviously a good thing for you and your
family and your security if you're gonna
burn my house down I'm gonna use it yeah
yeah like well if someone's exactly if
someone tries to burn your house down
they should know that it's on the table
like well if you try to burn my house
down and kill my family I will I will
shoot you to prevent that from occurring
you have the right to defend yourself
yeah from from the this violence and all
this stuff
so here we go what I'd like to say you
know especially in the past several
weeks just name a story around black
lives matter and it was fake name a
single black lives matter story that
wasn't fake I mean this is not not true
I want to make sure to clarify people
died yes there there is obviously some
some things were done wrong or
improperly but the point is the media
narratives coming out of all of these
stories were untrue to some degree yeah
and this is part of why I really want to
to dig into this is because as someone
on the the right and somebody's very
skeptical of BLM in their narratives
part of what sort of convinced me on the
the Brianna Taylor case and again this
is some coming from someone who didn't
pay as close attention to it as they did
some of the other ones is that you know
even Rand Paul was saying that we should
end no not grades which I agree with but
he titled his bill after Brianna Taylor
justice justice for Brianna Taylor so to
me and of course the mob still stopped
him and said say her name even though he
created well let's let's do this let's
let's start from the beginning because
we have John here yeah to just tell us
the story a lot of people don't know
about what went down with Brandon Taylor
I'm sure many activists will just accuse
you of lying but at the very least let's
see if you would like to you know give
us the breakdown of the story I know you
have a book about it but you can just
tell us what happened we'll go from
there yeah I'll give you the the 5 000
view story of it so that night
um we were asked to help what can you
know the date specifically yeah so March
12th is when the briefing was we didn't
breach the door until March 13th which
is Friday night full moon
um I came out from the briefing and I
had two flat tires it started pouring
down rain I got soaking wet while I was
moving my stuff from one car to the
other so everything was just kind of one
of those nights can you can you what was
the briefing it was for so we we had two
separate briefings SWAT did their
briefing because they were they were
executing the Warren Stone Elliott
um the guys who were assisting them that
were going to do the searches were at
our brief along with us all the the
houses that we were doing were on the
board they showed above of it
fortunately I took a picture it showed
above it no knock no knock no knock it
got to ours it said knocking an ounce so
they had changed it they were all signed
as no knocks so technically we served a
no knock warrant but it was not served
as a no knock uh if a signed by judges
of no knock but once it did not fit the
parameters of a no knock we didn't serve
it as a no knock we did the thing we're
supposed to do we corrected it and
didn't do it so the only reason it was
served it was written as a no knock is
because Jamarcus Glover's history he had
five I believe it was five felony
pending cases for guns and drugs he had
ran from the police and these were
Active cases not including the ones he
had already been charged with and pled
guilty to previously for Mississippi and
Louisville and so once they realized
they had a Ping On Us on his phone and a
tracker on his car they knew he would
not be on Springfield so they said we're
not doing that one as a no not because
it didn't justify being a no knock he
wasn't there and they set up we think
it's only Brianna Taylor at the house we
don't think there's any kids no dogs
nobody else there with her okay cool
they've been watching this house for a
while so I had assumed that their
intelligence was good on the house that
it was just going to be Brianna Taylor
they said she's a heavy set black female
give her time to come to the door give
her more time than usual because
normally it's about 10 seconds you're
banging on the door please search
warrant if you don't hear anything then
you go ahead and hit it so this one we
went we showed up and we gave it 45
seconds to a minute it was I think six
different cadences of knocking on the
door and yelling police search warrant
the first two were just regular knocks
hoping she would just come to the door
be quiet the neighbors wouldn't know
after she didn't come started banging
open hand really loud yelling police
search warrant the neighbor upstairs
heard us came out argued with our guys
they kept telling to go inside he didn't
want to go back inside
um so finally he did
we hit the door
once the door opened I could see from
right to left in the living room and I
was on the left of the door jamb and
Mike the guy who did the ram was on the
right because you never stand in the
Fatal funnel in case somebody shoots
through the door
so once the door came over I scanned to
the right to left everybody at this
point yelling police search warrant
please search warrant
when I turned the corner I had to step
right in the doorway just to see down
this Hall and as soon as I did there's
an ambient light coming out from the TV
down the hall we had lights on our guns
as soon as I turned the corner I saw two
people overlapping each other it was
like a Big Blob that with a tall head
and a short head and they were both down
in this hallways only maybe three four
feet wide at the most so very narrow
hallway because it had an inset where
Kenneth was standing that goes into the
next bedroom and that's Brianna's
boyfriend yes it's her boyfriend at this
time and so as soon as my eyes got to
Kenneth I never even got all the way to
Brianna even though they were like it
was basically one person but I never got
to her face as soon as I got to where
Kenneth was I could see the gun because
the flashlight all I saw was the metal
tip of the gun and my brain was like oh
and boom it was over he shot he shot
first yes he shot I felt it hit my leg I
returned fire I got four rounds off yeah
was the first shot fired it hit you yes
so so you open the door Kenneth what's
you know his last name Walker Walker
fires one round striking you in the leg
right and then the other officers return
fire correct I fired four I got offline
is what it's called so boom boom boom
real quick four shots got behind the
door frame came around shot two more at
that time I felt my leg realized there
was a ton of blood and I've seen you
know countless gunshot victims over 21
years and a normal leg shot that doesn't
hit an artery is it doesn't bleed much I
mean you might have a trickle of blood
down your leg that's it well this one as
soon as I put my hand on my thigh could
feel just a glob and I was like oh man
and I announced at the door I mean
everything happened so quick so I got
six rounds off in probably less than two
seconds I mean that's how quick this
whole exchange happens it's over before
you even realize what's going on
training kicks in and you just react so
I remember yelling it hit my femoral
artery and I sat down on my bottom
because I thought I can't I'm going to
pump the blood out that's what I was
thinking in my head and as I did that
Miles stepped up and was shooting
already and I thought I can't stay here
I'm gonna get shot by Crossfire so I
jump up and I hobble out and fall
between the cars and my lieutenant comes
up and they start working on me I'm like
dude I need to tourniquet get me a
tourniquet and they finally got one got
it on and got the bleeding stopped but
at that time you gotta people say well
why did why was there so many shots
fired 12 seconds in the dark the book
the title comes from the time that door
came open
until it was silent from no gunshots the
chaos stopped and that was about 10 to
12 seconds from what we've tried to
reenact it and see and so much happened
so much chaos so many things go through
your mind in that 12 seconds that it's
just amazing how much damage can be done
in that small amount of time and how
much aftermath damage the city the
country the nation from 12 seconds and
it's just it's it's sad so uh so you get
out of there you say you collapse
between two cars about how what was the
distance between between the door and
where you ended up on the ground with
getting medical attention so I'll try to
give you a visual of it if you're
looking at an apartment complex and they
have the the inside where the stairs go
up to the top you've got that little
foyer area which is maybe I don't know
12 feet deep and 10 feet wide that's
where we were at this is ground ground
floor ground floor and so I was all the
way on the inside so I hobbled out there
then a sidewalk a curb and then the
length of a car so I went down between
the cars but scooted to the edge to the
cars and that's when my lieutenant
grabbed my vest and pulled me out and
got to work but the thing about Kenneth
Walker you know he keeps saying he
didn't know it was the police first he
first he said nobody knocked and
announced then he comes back later and
goes yeah we heard him knocking we heard
him banging and I thought it was her
ex-boyfriend is what he said
um
so if you thought but then he said he
thought somebody was doing a home
invasion if you thought that why would
you have your girlfriend they got up got
dressed he retrieved a gun why would you
tell your girlfriend come in the hall
with me I'd imagine if he thought it was
her boyfriend
you know what I mean like they genuinely
but if you if you're that scared for
your life that you're willing to shoot
wouldn't you have her call 9-1-1
stay in here call 9-1-1 get them over
here I mean you know it's a tough
question about whether or not somebody
wants to call the police a situation
that's about to get hot whether they're
even thinking about it how someone
reacts I mean you know you're talking
about 12 seconds they hear a big bang
it's about 45 seconds I can't assume
these people would react the same way I
would I can't assume they trust cops you
know to come and resolve the problem but
more importantly I mean it's even fair
to say
they're not going to call the cops
because they might be involved in
illicit dealings or something and so
this is Street Justice that's probably
more the case so when they downloaded
his phone after the fact they found text
messages in there with him and other
guys you know those pictures of him with
this gun which is no big deal everybody
can have a gun uh but they had it also
with a bag of like pills that were
probably fentanyl pills because they
were the same little blue pills weed
whatever nobody cares about weed and so
but he was selling there's text message
in there him selling all this stuff to
different people that's irrelevant the
one that that stuck out was the one
where these other guys said hey do you
want to hit this lick with us and he
said well how much is it worth they said
20 grand and he was like it's fine but I
always do my homework first meaning he
sets up watches people see how they
react yeah and again this guy didn't
have a job he was getting ready to start
one day it was UPS the next day it was
postal I don't know which one it was but
he was getting ready to start a job
that's always the case getting ready to
get my life together
and so
a lot of times what these what these
drug dealers will do the Rob other drug
dealers that's just common practice they
won't report it to the police because
what are you going to say stole my drugs
money and but the way they do it is
they'll go up and they'll bang on a door
and yell police and when that door gets
open they've got a gun in and they rob
them that happens all the time you think
that's what he thought was happening I
don't know if that was his Mo of
previous cases that he had done so he
thought oh it's coming back on me yeah I
don't know it's hard to say because he's
lied so many times we don't know the
truth there's the simple uh uh
General circumstance Nuance excluded
that I've mentioned in the past that if
you're a law-abiding citizen armed
legally and someone kicks your door in
and you don't know it's the police you
have a right to defend yourself from a
home invasion I agree absolutely there
have been many you know stories I've
seen uh read about or a couple at least
where plain close cops you know are
serving a no knock warrant or something
and then they get shot and the person
ends up you know going to prison or
whatever and I'm like dude I think
that's horrible yeah but uh when you say
plain clothes let me let me correct this
because this was a big sticking point on
ours too because we were in what's
called plain clothes however we had
tactical vests on that said police
across the front yeah uh we had our
badges on
um you know seven white dudes going to a
black guy's house it's just not the norm
that's going to go rob a drug dealer
it's just not it doesn't happen
um
let's let's go ahead I'll just say let's
talk let's let's let's let's move
forward with the story a little bit and
talk about the lies so the big narrative
that comes out is that Brian Taylor was
sleeping in her bed and you guys just
basically shot into the house
willy-nilly killing her while she slept
you know the big thing not true we came
in in the middle of the night didn't not
didn't announce and killed her in her
sleep
so she was sleeping before we got there
but Ben crump's the one that kept
pushing this she was asleep in her bed
thing sleep over over he can't he came
out initially and said they even had the
wrong house they weren't even supposed
to be there and I'm going oh my God
we've got the we've got the search
warrant but our city refused to put it
out
they I'm like just showing the address
the name on it it's all you got to do
you know this doesn't hurt the
investigation one bit do you you
mentioned before that uh
they were gentrifying the area yes
something was going on with that what
was that about so down on Elliott which
is where Glover was at where they where
SWAT did the no Knocks for years they
have been buying up these properties
what they do is they go in and they
would condemn them buy them from the
homeowners for a buck a piece and so the
city had had taken the majority of that
block in 2000 I believe it was 18 they
had the University of Kentucky's
engineering department or architectural
Department draw up plans for this new
um vitalized area and it looked nice and
you do want areas like that to be
revitalized but you've got to do it the
right way you can't just go in and bully
people out of their houses and basically
steal it as a government I don't agree
with that so what they did was they sent
a map out through their through their
email and it had the houses they already
had marked off and it showed the houses
they needed to still get so in January
they started this new unit up called PBI
place-based investigations they got it
from Cincinnati and what that what this
was supposed to do is go after your most
violent or your most Troublesome areas
to clean up those neighborhoods because
even in these poor neighborhoods 80
percent of the people are great people
they really are they're just stuck in an
area that they can't get out of and I
think the government resources could be
used so much different to get these
people on their feet now for instance
and this is off topic of this but this
is just my little rant on this kind of
stuff because when you keep these people
entrapped like this and enslaved with
all the government assistance and their
inability to get out then it causes
these problems to compound and these
guys are looking for ways out by selling
drugs or robbing people or doing
whatever they have to do to survive I
mean it does become survival of the
fittest in some of these areas if you go
in these areas at night it's like a
third world country I mean you wouldn't
believe it and that's the problem with
most of the citizens they don't live in
those areas so they don't know what it's
like when you go after dark and there's
gunshots and there's fights and there's
I mean it's just you go oh my goodness
this wasn't like this two hours ago you
know when the sun was up it's just
different but I think they could go in
and and say you're on Section 8 or
assistance instead of just constantly
giving you money why don't they or I
mean these women get trapped okay here's
your assistance but if you make x amount
of money we're taking the assistance
away why don't you let them succeed in
their careers for five years and then
slowly taper off the assistance while
they're achieving this so they can get
out of this environment right I agree I
mean then in the end the government's
saving money because you're not keeping
these people on your payroll for their
entire life and you're helping the
community by getting them out and
getting them established and then 15 20
years from now when they're having kids
and their kids are having kids you've
got a totally different it's like
turning the pond over every year yeah
you know and you get you get new stuff
but on this case the gentrification he
was
they were they came in and a guy from uh
the mayor's office came in every single
week and met with this unit and all the
bosses all the assistant Chiefs would
come in and they would come in they
would talk about what they needed to do
to secure the rest of this what were you
doing they were going right on the
Whiteboard I was never involved in those
meetings didn't care didn't want to be I
had my own job but they were there every
single week and when this all came down
the mayor was like well I don't know why
they were there I have no idea and when
that came up the gentrification he was
like I didn't know anything about that
and but his name's on the emails yeah he
knew this was a guy from his office
conducting these meetings his a woman
that he ended up having an affair with
allegedly
was the project manager for this thing
so there's a lot of things that that are
going on this sounds like what actually
happened with the story is dirtier and
bigger than people realize I mean when
you mentioned that I'm like this sounds
like there's probably real estate
developers involved to go to the city
and say we want to turn a profit so he
says we're going to clean up this
neighborhood you got it well it's funny
he uses a certain friend
um I won't say his name but he uses a
certain friend they already redeveloped
one into the town that was a a real bad
into town it's called nulu now and it's
they've brought in restaurants and and
it's neat you know it's kind of a yuppie
area
but the same developer got all those
bids all those contracts and he was the
one that was going to get these so
there's a lot of under the table deals
going on and unfortunately the police
are always used as the pawns like we
were talking about earlier with the uh
with the vaccine stuff mandates
enforcing that yep if I can use the
police who have the authority as my
pawns to go do it then I can look back
and go man it wasn't me it was the case
but these cops need to say I'm not going
to 100 they do yes they do well let's
look I want to carry on the story though
so so here you are now you wake up in
the hospital uh uh Brad Taylor has died
uh did Kenneth get injured in any way no
So you you're what happens you pass out
on the ground no I stayed alert
conscious the whole time and I told
people and I've told people because I've
went around talked to some people about
critical incidents and you're not
required by law to give a statement
right away because in critical incidents
a lot of people if you wait a few days
some things you start remembering stuff
that you've you know for your own
protection you blocked out and but for
some reason when I woke up it was like
it was burned into my brain and I say I
wish I would have at least if I didn't
get my official statement I wish I would
have recorded it that day
because it hadn't changed one bit I mean
everything I said then I said now the
only things I forgot I forgot I'd put a
ball cap on that night because I got
rained on and I'm real conscious about
my hair so I threw a hat on because it
was all all messed up
um so I forgot about that but other than
that it was like
it was burned in me so
um but I waited 12 days to give a
statement because I was in the hospital
then recovering on pain meds and all
that and so that became an issue because
they were like oh it's a cover-up why do
you wait so long to give a statement I'm
like oh my gosh you know yeah this is my
statement it hadn't changed every
interview is the same but um so what did
you ask me on that particularly no just
just what happens next so you you you're
you're injured you stay up all night
you're in the hospital I'm wondering you
know what happens when you realize this
was turning into a national story there
were like was it riots are starting up
or or the news is picking it up so one
of the first things I asked my wife I
was like man was anybody hurt because I
didn't know I didn't know if anybody had
been shot in the apartment because you
know I was busy trying to tend to myself
and say stay alive
um and they told me yeah it was a female
and I was like crap because I knew when
I came there the taller one was probably
a guy I couldn't pick him out but you
know you kind of knew you can kind of
tell body types and I was like man
because every cop's biggest fear is at
least mine I can't speak for everybody
my biggest fear in this career has
always been I don't want to accidentally
shoot or kill the wrong person I mean
that's just a thought that you're
constantly playing because there's been
other times I could have been involved
in shootings where people pulled guns or
I've been shot at another warrant and
didn't return fire because I couldn't
see through what I was shooting at and
because the fear is always
I only want to do the right thing I
don't want to overstep these boundaries
and and in this position take somebody's
life because it's it's a pretty heavy
burden yeah and when that happened I was
like oh my goodness because after
Ferguson everything every cop shooting
that comes out now we go were they black
or white you know not was it a good
shoot or bad shoot which should be all
that matters color should not play any
relevance to it but it does so ever
since Michael Brown that's the question
were they black or white well I knew
Brown was black because I'd seen her
picture prior to this and so I was like
my goodness you know this is this isn't
going to be good I just kind of knew it
and however covet the nation shut down
on March 13th also that's when
everything shut down president was on
every day our governor was on every day
so it kind of got pushed down and I
think that's what our mayor and our
police chief counted on oh okay well if
this is the big story we can just this
will go away something else will come up
and then Ahmad Aubry happened
and Ben Crump was hired on Ahmad Aubry
well then after that one of the
attorneys on Brianna Taylor's case for
her mother
knew Ben Crump she had worked with him
on a case so she called him and said hey
can you help us on this one so he came
into town and then things had already
been there had already been lies or
misconceptions and part of that was the
police department's fault because they
didn't share any information with
Brianna Taylor's family either so I
understand their frustration I get it
um but then once he got on it was a
whole new animal man it was because he
already had the national Spotlight from
Ahmad Aubry so then now Brianna Taylor's
there and so I could feel the tension in
the city starting to creep up you could
feel it and I started reaching out to
people I even reached out to our uh city
council president who used to be a
police officer he was my training
officer in the academy
and I said man I texted him I've still
got on my phone I was like here's all
the lies they're saying and I listed it
it's pages of text and I said here's
what really happened and I told exactly
what I what I've told you guys and I
said the mayor won't say it what can we
do and he said yeah the mayor's refusing
to say this stuff I'll hold a press
conference Monday and get it out never
happened
for the you know when I hear the story
about you coming to the door and you
knock between 45 seconds in a minute I'm
wondering if you have any thoughts in
hindsight or if there's something else
that could be done to avoid this kind of
stuff
probably the last two years so I I'll
I'll write our major case unit before I
went to I had just transitioned to the
the parcel interdiction unit because I
think I was thinking man I probably got
four years left before I'm going to
retire I wanted to kind of bring slow
things down I'd already I already made
entry in over 2000 search warrants and
doors and I thought to myself I thought
the Luck's gonna run out you know it's
just it's a numbers thing it's an odd
eventually I'm going to be in a critical
incident I don't want to be so let's go
ahead and start let's start tapering
this career off slowing down because
I've been going 100 miles an hour for
probably 15 of my 20 years with search
warrants and drugs and all that and uh
so I wanted to I wanted to transition
and
the last two years I had constantly
thought about two things that bothered
me number one eventually something's
going to happen but the main thing was
as I matured as a person and as a dad
and all that once we would go through
these doors you would have three four
five six-year-old kids just terrified
you know all of a sudden you've got
eight ten cops coming in with guns
screaming putting people on the ground
and that started affecting me that
started making me go man this just ain't
worth it you know I we're traumatizing
these kids I can understand why they
grew up hating the police
you know you start thinking of all these
things and I'm going
we've got to do something different so
we started pulling people off we'd wait
till they leave their house they were at
a gas station Barber Shop wherever and
we'd start grabbing them up because it
it lowered our risk and it lowered their
risk and it lowered the trauma on these
kids so that was pretty big to me so we
had done that probably in 80 of the
cases the last two years I was up there
this wasn't my call we were helping out
so we did what they asked we did what
they asked us to do have we if I could
do it different if none of the Dynamics
changed because people go why did you
have to do why did you have to go there
at 12 30 at night if she wasn't a threat
if she wasn't the main target she was
one of the targets but she wasn't the
main target and I tried to explain to
people because word gets out so quick
when you do a warrant I mean it's even
before the internet we used to call it a
probably gonna get in trouble for this
but I'm gonna say it we used to call it
the ghetto net because it was like and
it doesn't matter if it's black or white
it was just if you hit a door
everybody everybody knew man I mean they
just knew calls went out and so when you
do these type things where where
evidence might be at different locations
you do them simultaneously so nothing is
destroyed because that's what you take
into court uh Glover Glover's car was
registered to bring on his house his
bank account uh when he bonded out of
jail was there his cell phone was
registered there everything was in her
name or at her house that was glubbers
so they wanted that evidence to tie him
in to that house because they had
pictures of him coming there getting
packages leaving uh Brianna taking him
down to the trap house dropping stuff
off so that was the brown there was Evan
I said she was involved in this stuff
yeah after the fact they pulled Glover's
phone calls
and he's talking to his baby mama and he
said uh I need somebody to go to
Brianna's house and see if the cops miss
that money and she was like oh you were
letting her hold your money why was she
holding your money you know she was mad
and he was like well she holds a lot of
people's money that's just what she does
so it was was she slinging the dope I
don't think so I don't think physically
she was taking so and though but she was
part of the organization in a peripheral
way bonded him out of jail letting him
use her address for Stuff
um holding money so she was tied into it
and people always go I hate this phrase
oh you think you're judged during
execution I'm going no I was just trying
to save my life and this wasn't a
payment for the crime you know this
wasn't that that's not the intent here
so that that aggravates me when people
say that
I worry that uh people don't understand
there may not be solutions to these
things
so you know you you look you've got
someone who's selling illegal drugs very
dangerous ones I mean what was the
suspected of uh fentanyl We Believe
fentanyl we know uh meth uh but yeah
fentanyl he had the pills so you know
you can come out and make an argument
about the legalization of drugs but when
you start getting into areas about
fentanyl you start getting harder
questions there are some Libertarians
who are outright like no no people can
take whatever they want whatever they
want and I'm like you know I I get that
I get that but the question is even
still even then there's still going to
be some restrictions on how much or or
to children I mean you got to prevent
these things so ultimately what ends up
happening is we've got a big we've got a
big Society you've got people on the
left on the right Libertarians
authoritarians and everyone's got a
different view which means ultimately
there's compromise the compromise we
have right now whether people like it or
not is that if somebody is illegally
selling very serious drugs we're going
to stop them I think most people the
overwhelming majority of people are
going to be like yeah I don't want
someone selling fentanyl in my area
because you don't know who he's selling
to and it's An Extremely Dangerous Drug
you you go you go to local people and
say say someone's selling you know
marijuana or something like that and
they're going to roll their eyes and be
like is this a priority right now so the
fentanyl matters and if that's the case
and there are parents who want their
neighborhoods cleaned up and they don't
want these drugs around well then
someone's got to stop it but that means
you're gonna have to have police going
and serving warrants and and what people
need to understand like you said
simultaneously all at the same time
and relatively late for for strategic
reasons and also probably for safety
reasons for you've got less people who
are out and about things like that
then you have to contend with the fact
that people are allowed to defend
themselves in their homes no one's going
to take that away at least some people
are trying to and this means that you
get a perfect storm a warn is being
served nobody answers the door gets gets
it's you know kicked in and then the guy
shoots whether it was it whether it was
an accident or whether it was he didn't
know you were cops or did regardless the
conflict starts someone loses their life
you some people you know these activists
especially think there's something that
can be done or has to be done and maybe
I'm not saying we don't investigate and
try and figure out ways to solve these
problems but man some people got to
realize that
there may always be this cause and
effect that exists within with within
this system at least as we've defined it
right now if people have a right to keep
and bear arms in their homes to defend
themselves and we expect police to shut
down people selling drugs very serious
ones you'll get a situation like this
and people will people will die and
there can be uh you know I think one of
the authors he fired rounds that went to
other other apartments or something like
that yeah so the walls were co-joined
the the kitchen walls and that was one
of the that was one of the mistakes in
this thing not him shooting because
he thought we were getting executed at
that doorway you had metal and concrete
and the rapid shots and he thought oh
man he knew I'd gone down he thought
dude they're getting killed at the door
I got to do something yeah but the
problem is we weren't provided a map of
the layout of how that other apartment
was butted up yeah and from the outside
looking at it it doesn't look like it it
looks like they're separate you know
things right so if you hadn't been in it
or hadn't looked at the actual layout so
there were some mistakes made don't get
me wrong no for sure for sure I I what I
mean to say is just in a bigger picture
I'm I'm reminded of this story out of
Europe where I think it was in Denmark
there was a mass shooter and maybe it
wasn't Denmark it was a country up in in
Europe and after the shooting happened
they mourned and then did nothing and
they said well sometimes people are
crazy and they get guns you know what
what are we supposed to do right this
this was an it was an aberration it
wasn't a fault of the system it was a
fault of sometimes people you know do
bad things and that's that that's the
challenge I see with this I certainly
think there's there's uh ways to reform
and there needs to be there there needs
to be at least on a criminal justice
system very serious reforms but my point
is
if people are unwilling to confront the
system in any meaningful way and I mean
like the writers are not confronting in
any meaningful way the system doesn't
change in fact the writers are probably
only making it worse because now you're
going to get more regular people saying
more more weapons for the cops just shut
it all down they're gonna say get
tougher get more aggressive then you're
going to get activists who are like my
friend was beaten by the cops well it's
because the community is demanding you
know these these things that shut down
you get people calling the mayor's
office the mayor calls the you know goes
gets the cops on the radio and says I
don't care what you do just shut down
the protest shut down the riots the cops
say okay get it done the people complain
and it's an endless cycle the the issue
I take with a lot of this is
these people who live in these cities
they're the ones who are voting in these
Democratic politicians who don't care
about them right demanding of them
police action on crime
then when when when the action on crime
results in some kind of
um
accidents or a brutal event it's these
same people who are now complaining
about that event out marching in the
streets is one of the reasons that I
want to live in these cities anymore
because it seems like these people don't
have a logical process in their mind as
to why these things are happening they
just say I don't understand why there's
got to be crime and I also don't
understand why you know cops are so mean
and I don't understand why people are
getting beaten and it's like because
people are shooting each other and
because you want the shooting to stop so
the cops go out and the cops are scared
of getting shot and then some cops get
shot and then cops shoot back and then
you complain the cops shot back I'm like
I don't know well that's like the
majority of our loudest mouth protesters
and I'm not talking about somebody
really wanting change walking with the
sign doing it the right way I'm talking
about the guys that were jumping on cars
taunting police
um
constantly in people's face I mean if
there was a cheerleading competition of
little girls in downtown Louisville
during this it was near the it was a
little bit further in so I think they
thought it was safe enough but it wasn't
and these guys were getting these
parents and these kids face and saying
some or rape your kids I mean all kinds
of crazy stuff
and then they want to say the police are
the problem and all these guys who are
out here for reform and stuff that were
doing this all have had huge criminal
records there's like three of them that
have been killed since the riot started
that were the major drivers behind this
stuff two of them shot in the head and
you know all three were shot in the head
one was in a carjacking so that may have
been uh accidental but the other two
were targeted hits and the funny thing
is the the rumor in the city was all the
the people who disagree with the police
were going oh the police are out there
killing all the protesters and we're
going you kidding me because they caught
somebody on all of them you know well
there was uh in in first lifestyle I
mean and Ferguson I believe it was uh
they found a vehicle with a with someone
killed in the front seat I think that's
what it was it's been it's been a minute
I don't know if you've heard that story
or whatever it wasn't the cops who did
it although
the activists are pushing that there's a
conspiracy theater conspiracy theory out
of Ferguson the police are going around
and executing the people who organized
the protest that's what they're saying
in Louisville that's crazy man it's like
a couple weeks probably a month ago now
there was a police chase a guy had shot
somebody robbed him shot him they're
chasing him
um he wrecked out he eats his gun boom
kills himself
so they've got their body cameras on and
car cameras but ever since our case
before Brianna Taylor
when our city investigated the thing
they they would Release Body cam footage
within 24 hours
and but in our case they said since
there was no body cam they were like
well we can't talk about the case and I
said what's the difference in releasing
body Cam that shows everything or
disputing the lies well they didn't have
an answer for it naturally but because
since then the state police took over
investigating because they were like the
protesters that was one of their demands
we don't want LMP to investigating fine
well let's stay please do it so now the
state police investigate their policy is
we don't Release Body cam footage till
we're ready until we've investigated
enough screw you we're going to do
whatever we want and now they're saying
and they were they had three days of
protest saying oh it's a cover-up the
police went up and shot him in the head
he didn't shoot himself yep so it's just
it doesn't matter what you do it's going
to be though they're like like we said
earlier there's that Fringe on both
sides that are just crazy on the right
and the left that no matter what you do
it's not going to be right I always try
to uh clarify in that that it's true but
it seems to be the uh the exception for
the right and the rule for the left yeah
the the conservative media apparatus
tends to get stories correct the liberal
establishment media apparatus tends to
get stories wrong and it's probably
because these are Big corporate Outlets
that are driven by profit whereas
conservative Outlets tend to be driven
by Passion ideology idea or ideology
that is not that is I am not saying that
one side is right or wrong you know
because a lot of people hear that it's
this is fascinating and they're like
you're saying the right is good and I'm
like
conservative news outlets are you know
small budget passion projects where
people are like I believe in this I want
to push a story out so they tend to be
trying to follow the facts but with the
conservative perspective with
conservative commentary and opinion the
establishment's just like put whatever
gets us the clicks man yeah well truth
be told there's a lot of ideology behind
it as well with trying to get Democrats
elected but let me talk to you about uh
the issue I've had with the cops uh you
know my concerns and and discontent is
you know covet after uh the George Floyd
riots you know I was very much like if
there's one thing I think any any person
can agree on that police should be doing
is stopping rioting stopping direct
crime against individuals violent crime
and things like that you want to argue
about drugs being legal all the
libertarian stuff it's like okay okay
we've got the debate about that but we
all we all agree like if people are
running around burning down buildings we
would appreciate a police force to be
like hey stop doing that
the problem is and there's reasons
behind this but for one we saw in New
York cops were standing down we saw in
many of these circumstances cops
standing down we know why as you were
mentioning it's too dangerous and they
have no support from the community so
I'm not gonna you know go and and cheer
on the people who live in New York City
for voting for and supporting the
problems they're causing themselves but
when I saw the police even local
sheriffs going to Cafe owners and salon
owners and arresting them or finding
them or shutting down their businesses
over covid I was like now you lost me
you know I I can come out all day and
say that the regular working class cop
you know is not a racist that those are
media lies and narratives these stories
are are few and far between their rare
circumstances but man the stuff we saw
around police shutting down people's
livelihood Lively this was everywhere
you had attila's gym cops showed up shut
them down even arrested I think one guy
got arrested the government issued all
these fines and the police are the ones
backing it up in North Jersey you had a
woman whose store was closed and she was
live streaming her products cops showed
up and shut her down you had a sheriff's
department in Minnesota chase a woman or
or uh it was an Iowa Department I
believe apprehend a woman because she
had opened her coffee house during
lockdown and with a smile on their face
they they they grabbed these people with
and that blows my mind how how is that
and you know explain to me that mindset
that you could be a cop and be like how
dare this lady do someone's hair I'm
gonna arrest her that to me is insane it
is insane I think
I mean it's it's tough because I don't I
don't want to bash the cops but you can
look on my Twitter feed from months ago
when this was happening and I said the
same thing I said
guys you're being played
they're using you as their henchmen and
you're being played you've got to do the
right thing everybody's stand down and
but I also think there's got to be some
responsibility on the other side too for
the people that want to make a point
like when you go into a restaurant
that's private and they go
hey I've got a I've gotta abide by this
or the police will come in and find me
if I don't and they're like screw that I
want my food but I can't because you're
not you're not abiding by this even
though it's an unlawful mandate I agree
with that
but neither should have fear of serving
or getting food but because of our
government they're enforcing these
mandates that are unconstitutional and
then
both of them are this this owner is in
fear of losing his livelihood this guy's
trying to prove a point that I don't
have to follow these illegal mandates
and then the cop comes in
you know and he probably agrees with
both of them honestly and is like man
these are stupid but what am I supposed
to do here if I don't do this my body
cams on now I'm going to lose my job in
my livelihood and he should yeah I mean
absolutely I mean if you're going to
take a stand if you're going to
sacrifice you've got to do it I mean but
they can't if they all stood up and said
no they couldn't fire them all right I
don't I'm not saying the cops should be
fired uh uh technically I'm saying the
cops should uh gladly recognize the
system is broken you've become the
villain if you know and people say to me
you don't understand you you need your
job you got to pay your bills and my
response is like I totally get it you
know people don't seem to understand
because they're like oh look how
successful you are Tim it's easy for you
to say and I'm like it I've always said
it even when I was broke it's what leads
me to the point of success and I'm
unwilling to to compromise with the with
with this kind of you know aimoral
Behavior or illegality at the very least
I could recognize the cop
starting you know these officers and
many have planning their Exodus from
these departments for other areas look
at what Florida said Florida we had
Billboards out uh not out here where
were they I think there was one out here
actually Billboards in like the DC area
sang become a police officer in Florida
now hiring benefits yeah Florida where
we have your back yeah yeah well and and
they said we got no mandates you don't
gotta do this stuff don't have to do it
I think people need to realize you're
not trapped in this one job but what I
wish my point being
I agree with the no mandates I was a
pushed the limit on not wearing a mask
I'm not vaxed I'm not anti-vaccine I'm
not anti-vaccine I can't lie and say you
are you know yeah whatever uh yeah
anything that you disagree with you get
hammered but uh so I'm not vexed I
hardly ever wore a mask unless I'm
flying just because I got to get
somewhere and maybe that's hypocritical
of me too but the point is go make your
statement go in there have the police
call on you but when they come there
instead of giving the cop a hard time to
go you've made your point right if you
want to pick it outside do it I agree
with that actually but they really don't
want that hamburger they want to make a
point and I get it but do it where
you're not harming the other people that
kind of agree with you you know we have
a we have a lesson in skateboarding when
we're little it's a younger if when
you're skateboarding in the streets
meaning you're going to corporate
buildings or you're at loading docks
behind you know warehouses you can skate
and as soon as you see a security guard
you leave yeah when the security guard
walks up and says hey you can't scare
you go sorry about that and you leave
and then when he leaves you come back
you come right back yeah well I I would
I would not advocate for immediately
coming back if you're told you're
trespassing you're trespassing you
shouldn't trespass but the point is that
if you leave right away you don't blow
up the spot as we would call it meaning
other people have heard about it they
might end up showing up we've had kids
you know I remember this man they
smashed a window because security guard
told them to leave and I'm like they
just ruin everything for everybody so
now you'll never be able to come back
here because they'll set up something
where you can't so you know I think
about this and I'm like imagine going
into a restaurant and they say you can't
be in here there's a mandate and they
say I'm not leaving because you're
discriminating against me and they say
well I'm going to call the police say
okay call the police in every
Circumstance the cop have showed up and
said you've been informing your
trespassing you're being warned to leave
at that point you can be like okay walk
out the front door wait for the cops to
go walk back in and say I want a
cheeseburger and that causes a bigger
problem than having some cop arrest you
and then inconvenience inconveniencing
yourself and if you look at the bigger
picture here's what this is done now
this has taken
we've already had a divided country
right in 2020 we were pretty you had
this group in this group that believed
two different things Cops Bad Cops good
now what they've done is they've
subdivided the good cop part because
they're using them to enforce laws on
people that supported the cops but now
the cops have to stand up to those
people and now they're mad at the cops
so now the left wins again because
they've broken us even more and we're
weaker in in New York
they had 27 police officers defending
what was an illegal painting in the
street Bill de Blasio sees taxpayer
funds illegally to paint black lives
matter in front of Trump's building and
27 cops with smiles on their faces
guarded that illegal act
now look I I understand these are cops
who live in New York City so they're
probably Democrats and then you but but
surprising to me it's like how could you
live in a city where the people who vote
for the politicians who appoint the the
commissioner or the the chief of police
and then hire these these other cops
you're the villain in this whole story
to everyone right the cops defending the
black lives matter mural are villains to
the left already and for defending the
illegal actions of the mayor their
villains to the right I I you got to be
I it takes a special kind of resolve to
decide that you want to be hated by
everybody and but but truth be told it's
not always the wrong choice sometimes
being hated by everybody is the right
thing to do in this instance I don't
think so a challenge I guess is
you know people people it's hard to just
quit your job when you got a mortgage
when you got kids and that's the the the
the that's the news man well they get
you it's it's no different than what
we're what I was talking about a few
minutes ago with all the government
subsidies they get you trapped
and you can't do anything you know
unless you take a leap of faith or you
get a good opportunity I mean they get
you trapped there too this is this is
it's it's sad and it's scary because
it's just like it's slavery Democrats
are pushing uh policies that put more
people in positions where they can't
leave their jobs and are desperate and
that's what it is that's the boot on
your neck yeah so when you got what was
it Joe Biden was talking about this
policy for urbanizing the suburbs I
don't know if you saw this one the idea
was to build more trains going into the
suburbs to to do ban single single
Housing Development things like that oh
yes that would create more desperation
and destitution which they then can
manipulate by saying you can't quit your
job you could only afford to live in
this extremely high cost of living area
on with loans and then if you lose your
job you can't pay off your loans and
then we're gonna come for your kids and
people say okay okay you got me I'll
enforce whatever you say and there it is
if everyone just said no these problems
would be solved instantly what if I just
took my mortgage out as a student alone
will the government forgive it well
they're not doing that that's what's
funny all the other progressives were
like yeah Biden forgive student loans
and he was like nah yeah I need to take
those billions and send them into the
Middle East well to be fair you can you
can file bankruptcy uh uh and get a lot
of your debt you know wipes but uh not
for student loans yeah so if you get
student loans I'm not a fan of the
student loan system I think I worked
three jobs in college so I don't feel
sorry for them but I do I do think
personally we can we can do something
about the interest rates oh yeah yeah I
would agree on the interest that's where
everybody agrees or how come colleges
can increase their percentage of tuition
every year so much I mean it just keeps
climbing because they want you to be an
indentured servant because when you've
got student loans you can't quit your
job you can't file bankruptcy on student
loans they've got you locked up and you
don't even realize they got you locked
up but a lot of people are starting to
realize it now here's what else happens
they use that to once again manipulate
those they've already locked into a
dentured servitude with ridiculous we'll
forgive your student student loans vote
for us and then what happens Biden's
like no just kidding Jessica switch yeah
it would be nice if Donald Trump said
we're gonna deal he did suspend loans I
believe on during coven I think I think
Donald Trump if he gets elected I think
there should be some kind of executive
action because these are these are
Federal loans I think they have the
authority to do this I'm not sure just
say interest rates shut down right again
back what you what you borrowed yeah
it's kind of like the thing earlier with
the you know getting people back on
their feet right they don't have to get
interest on them just get your money
back
you borrowed it you use the money you
got to pay it back because a lot of
those loans weren't just for school they
got that that cost of living stuff too
they could buy food pay for their
Apartments whatever else you got to pay
it all back yeah if they gave you 50
Grand I think you got to pay it back and
we should discuss how that inflation
Works into that however you know I know
people who have taken out like 20 000 in
loans and now they own 40 and they've
already paid back 40. and it's just like
saying yeah these stories are insane
right so I I think you gotta a lot of
the I I think the populist right
understands all of this I think
conservative Inc often doesn't you know
the more like establishment not so much
establishment but a lot of these uh
conservatives say like yeah those are
your responsibility you you took out the
loans you signed the contract and I'm
like that's true I agree with that I
don't agree with making someone Pay Back
40 Grand on a 17 000 loan that's insane
yeah now we're getting to the point
where the point of school loans and the
reason you can't be declaring bankruptcy
in my opinion or what I thought was that
we're going to help Kickstart your life
to get you a good skill set good career
crippling them so they can't have
families and buy houses it's just bad
for everybody the government turned into
the mafia yeah yeah you'll never get me
paid off yeah well and of course these
uh these loans are subsidized by the
government the entire idea is they're
going to guarantee the student loans and
that's only resulted in colleges raising
tuition costs and all you have instances
where someone will borrow 20 000 they'll
end up paying Back Forty thousand you
just have to ask the question is it
really a productive use of economic
resources to have entire groups of
people whose career is to live off of
the interest of loans that were lent out
prior that have already been more than
paid back is that really the best use of
uh human willpower and thought and labor
for someone to just be in a position
where they're living off of Interest
think about it I don't think so we're
wondering why it is that a police
officer is going to arrest someone who
owns a salon and that's why and if you
are an authoritarian in government the
last thing you want is for police
officers especially to say men of good
conscience do not follow unjust orders
but when they say we'll take your kids
we'll take your house and you'll be on
the street and you'll see how quickly
people are willing to bend over
backwards yeah well it also I mean it
makes sense again given the way
inflation Works to charge some level of
interest on a loan but you know once
it's once you're paying back
significantly significantly more than
you took out I think it's it's pretty
criminal and also uh you know when you
look at real estate yeah I mean a lot of
people are in debt because they're
paying off a mortgage mortgage but
they're building Equity you look at
these people who have way overpaid for
these degrees that are really useless
and for someone's you know for these
Banks to get to be getting rich off of
this government policy is just a
redistribution of wealth from taxpayers
and from these young people who took
loans out to the big Banks I don't I
just don't see how conservatives could
consider that to be acceptable it's big
government intervening on behalf of
business and on behalf of the banks to
protect their profits or give them more
what's the problem big government their
hands in way too much I think we need a
very small federal government and it's
yeah they they're trying to control
everything but but I do think there's
something that the tides have turned I
do think that
freedom
honesty and integrity
I think that's winning a lot of these
these moral values are probably probably
vetoes conservative because I don't know
if you've ever looked at Jonathan
Heights moral foundations research no
there's six moral foundations the left
has two care and fairness
so they don't have a Authority they
don't have loyalty they don't have
Purity and they don't have Liberty those
are the other I believe those are the
other ones I could be making but I'm
pretty sure that's it conservative
conservatives have all of them all six
in in Fairly equal amounts my favorite
Point here is that Libertarians have won
just Liberty Liberty like seriously
Libertarians like uh when they they
initially had five moral foundations
then realized something was missing
because some some people had nothing and
they're like what is this and it was
like oh because they only care about
people being allowed to do their own
thing and be left alone and Libertarians
you know they they there was a
what was it someone got booed for saying
that uh you should be allowed to sell
drugs Austin Peterson
Peterson okay dude and not to be fair I
think they were rejecting his framing
but still a very no but Gary Johnson
tweeted like the libertarian party of
New Hampshire said like oh no bring back
child labor maybe it was Gary Johnson
who was booed I don't maybe it wasn't
Austin Peterson I need to double check
the libertarian party of New Hampshire
said you know legalize child labor yeah
and Gary Johnson was like no no like
this is not only need and and that's
like people are are we you see the
slippery slope because now with the you
know trying to teach these
kindergartners about transsexuals and
sex period that it's it's where does it
stop where do you draw the line and go
okay this is it no more well that's a
whole other conversation right yeah but
uh uh you know the point I'm bringing up
with the moral foundations is that a lot
of the things that uh we we want to be
winning
are more typical are typical of
conservatives like uh like loyalty uh um
and Purity is another more Foundation
Purity meaning like you don't want
children being abused or exposed but
this is not a moral Foundation that
exists among the left for the most part
so it's typically conservative but my
point was uh I think these moral
foundations are starting to win and I
think it has a lot to do with the
internet with uh podcasts the ability of
people to to form communities online but
what needs to happen more of which is
happening is people standing up speaking
up and just standing firm and saying you
know I'm not going to do something that
is that is a violation of these
foundations because what I will tell you
is
if the moral foundations the six that
are winning uh indicate that
conservatives tend to be winning uh and
conserve isn't necessarily the right
answer because libertarian post-liberal
conservative but it just means that
ideas like loyalty are winning
that's not with that not being on the
left you can understand why they're why
the left is angry about it and why the
left would force or convince a
conservative or libertarian to abandon a
moral foundation for personal gain so if
you're a conservative and you have all
of the moral foundations and loyalty is
something that's important to you and
then you see something that is an
egregious violation of say loyalty to
the country that doesn't mean blind
loyalty it means like we're going to
stand by and support you know our our
troops we're going to stand by and
support our law enforcement or genuinely
trying again not blindly right
legitimately
the left would say no don't do that
don't be a loyal to your community when
when when we say with the boot on your
neck you're not allowed to sell coffee
we want you to abandon your moral
foundations and do what we want because
we have none and because of the way
they've put the boot down you've got
cops who are like yes sir whatever you
say and that's horrifying but if people
just assert themselves well so I'll
without repeating myself the point is I
think the moral foundations typically
associated with the right are winning
and that means given a long enough
period of time things are going to
genuinely improve
unless nukes I guess yeah but you know
that's a whole other conversation so or
you know I mean you got to go back to
the school thing if if the
indoctrination doesn't change in the
schools and not just sexual stuff but
I'm talking about just overall the
thinking there's no critical thinking
being taught everything's just
everything's just regurgitation here's
what to believe you're gonna do it okay
that's what we believe we want critical
thinking they want critical feelings
they want you do you how do you feel how
do you feel about something and it's
like it's it's it's it's like an archaic
way of living you know we we logic
reason understanding compassion these
things came together to help make
Humanity strive and strength and
stronger and successful another do away
with the things that helped us you know
and just go back to just how things feel
that's why when I interview with Strahan
we got into a big argument over it
because he was like yeah well I just
feel this black people just feel this
I'm like well Michael you know your
feelings are important but just because
you feel it doesn't mean it true right
you know I feel lot of things that
aren't true yeah my kids they feel like
I'm being mean to them when I make them
go to bed or get off the computer or it
doesn't mean it's true but you're doing
it because you love them and you want to
or my I won't let my dog out of the yard
so it doesn't get hit by a car he thinks
I'm being mean to it yeah you know our
cat bocus he yells at me because we'll
let him outside but it's 20 degrees out
he can't go outside normally we let him
go out and do whatever he wants and he's
complaining and I'm like bro you're
protecting you yes but they don't get it
all right let's go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends we're gonna have a
members only version of the podcast
going up around 11 p.m tonight over at
timcast.com so make sure you support our
work and uh get in your questions now
for uh uh uh Sergeant John Mattingly do
I still call you Sergeant John just John
for John uh I I'm I'm certain that we
didn't get to a lot of your thoughts and
questions about what happened with
Brianna Taylor so seriously we're going
to go through some of the super why they
got about the book buy the book yeah
there's some awesome stuff in there that
nobody knows about but people this
opportunity to ask questions about uh
what you what what you think uh and
anything your your uh you have any
questions about uh questions about what
happened at night we can we can we can
get these answered so let's read some
super chats
all right let's see I can't read the
name of the first Super Chat because
that's how YouTube is they say I gotta
push back when you say rich people can't
give away money I believe this is a
translation problem it's okay but I
believe you said Art Auction wrong never
forget wall banana yeah that's true
there are there are ways to sort of give
away money but what I meant was
literally give away money uh obviously
you can try and bypass and seek out
loopholes what I mean is you would think
that a human being could walk up to
another person and be like I just wanted
to give you money you know and make your
life better you can't do that up to
fifteen thousand dollars you can for the
average American that's substantial
enough to where you can give money away
but what I mean is if you're rich and
you're like I would like to buy someone
a car can't do it Oprah bottle gave
other people cars remember and they had
to pay taxes on them most of them had to
sell them yeah and they sold them to to
taxes right right right so it just you
can't just do it I think uh you know we
were talking to Jeremy boring of uh uh
daily wire co-ceo
and uh we were talking about how you
know when you first come into money you
you all of a sudden see this Maze of
what the government has set up as to how
you can how you can operate what you can
or can't do when you start a company
people really don't get it they're like
why don't you hire me to do this and I'm
like that would be illegal and they're
like like you can't hire me to be a
consultant I'm like no imagine telling
the IRS yeah we hired a guy doesn't do
anything we pay him a lot of money
they're going to be great you're trying
to bypass laws and taxes so we're going
to come after you and find you people
don't get it like every employee has to
have a quantifiable job with a title
with a market rate salary slightly above
or below otherwise you get investigated
or fine and all of that stuff has to be
followed to the T I wish it was as
simple as to just be like you can do
whatever you want but we got enough
regulations man yeah we do all right
let's see we got
a book of cloud says well chicken city
is here what does that mean we got
chicken City I don't know go to
youtube.com chicken City And subscribe
if you haven't already because it's uh
soothing nature sounds of roosters
screaming and birds and woodpeckers and
all that stuff cats love it
all right
the general huge rooster out there yeah
he's a big he's a big boy yeah he's a
big boy runs with some Bad Dudes King of
the Hill that's right he's got his son's
out there and it's really funny because
uh with chickens you know the rooster
bangs all the chickens then they have
eggs and then when the eggs hatch boys
come out and the roost is all of a
sudden like ah
exactly and he gets mad and he's like
now you know it only takes six months
for his son to be challenging him for
you know the ladies and it's like well
you're the one who's making them you
know what I mean
they do uh they they do castrate uh
roosters it's called something else
really yeah they cut through the back
and like disable and then they like
their chicken eunuchs I guess I'm glad
I'm not a rooster yeah that's if you
that's if you have boys and you want to
grow and eat them so they castrate them
so you can otherwise versus apparently
are like hard to eat you can eat them
you can basically eat a lot of things
but you know
all right let's see we got
as
Dog Log says will you be making a
YouTube channel for your on the ground
reporting how about live reporting now
that starlink is coming now Tim cast
news van we've certainly got some ideas
but I don't think we need a YouTube
channel to be honest you'll probably
just put it on the website I don't know
if I I think YouTube has uh I think
YouTube destroyed itself a long time ago
see they gave everything to CNN they
gave everything to all these big uh
these big networks but now these big
networks are pulling off and starting
their own streaming platforms Fox Nation
CNN Plus
so YouTube has shown disloyalty to those
who are who are using their platform if
I'm going to launch something new it
ain't gonna be on YouTube it's going to
be on rumble or it's going to be on the
website and I'm talking about like
substantive stuff obviously we will
still put our stuff on YouTube like
inverted World we'll go up there pop
culture crisis yeah but do you think
Rumble will ever get up to the to be
able to pay you like YouTube is
well that's the problem with a lot of
people it's kind of like the the thing
we're talking about earlier with cops
you know people think well YouTube's
censoring these people and I'm ticked
off at YouTube but I can't leave because
that's my financial source so YouTube uh
pays well but I will I will say
the real benefit from YouTube is
marketing and that's it but they're not
doing that anymore so obviously we make
money on YouTube
we make most of our most of our business
is is supported through memberships
so if we got banned from YouTube tonight
we would be completely fine able to keep
operating it would be pretty bad you
know Crowder got booted out of the
partner program but he was like we're
good we're going to keep doing our thing
like normal and then eventually he got
let back in so but uh YouTube has has
really hurt itself
now that all of these companies are
launching their own platforms they're
taking their content off of YouTube and
they're putting it on their own shows
YouTube's going to be left holding an
empty bag because YouTube and YouTube
will have no choice but to try and do
YouTube Originals which failed because
it just doesn't work YouTube is not a
streaming service the way they want it
to be so the more they they they spit in
our faces the the
I got to be honest you've got a bunch of
political commentators you've got a
bunch of big YouTubers and YouTube
should be doing everything to kiss their
asses because CNN plus launched today
and that means their authoritative news
source they're I guarantee the president
of CNN or whatever is probably like how
do we get our vid our views off of
YouTube and onto our platform
we have similar discussions how do we
get people to watch more on timcast.com
and head over to timcast.com well this
show is Live on YouTube then it gets
uploaded and we use YouTube's
infrastructure because it actually does
save us a lot of money for CNN who's
already backed and worth you know
hundreds of millions or whatever dollars
and has all this access they don't need
YouTube's infrastructure and they're
going to pull out and then YouTube's
going to be sitting there saying who's
our news source people are going to go
there and search CNN ain't going to come
up or something will but it'll be hey go
to cnn.com for more information and then
they have these shows which are long
form and they're and they're treating us
like trash so
we'll see how things how things go Ben
Dover says will of the people I'm an
expert in empathy I'm Irish yes that's
true there you go
that's right if you haven't already uh
search will of the people timcast and
listen to the music video you know we
put this out in November 2nd of uh 2020.
it's becoming particularly relevant now
because of the the whole Muse thing and
we do have a couple songs that are
entering the animation phase they've
already been storyboarded and uh the
next songs in our series that follow
this universe about a country in tumult
and the and the themes and ideas around
uh Civil War Revolution and
international conflict in crisis so uh
those will come out soon but you can
check that out
all right let's read some more Joe Burns
says hey Tim and friends look up the
episode of Doctor Who known as the long
game it features chilling's story on
info manipulation and fake news oh that
sounds fun I will check that out
vasht says we all survived World War Z
yeah the Z symbol for the Russians maybe
this will uh finally be over
Joseph says you wrote will of the people
Tim you must understand to some degree
no one has the answer key to this
existence we move the world through our
choices I believe in what you were what
you're doing heart appreciate it yeah I
think one of the ideas of will of the
people for those that have seen it and
the themes around it isn't that everyone
thinks they're right it's kind of like
what I was saying that sometimes there
are no solutions that maybe maybe it is
just the nature of humanity to go
through Cycles
people want to believe in this utopian
Vision where we finally reach the top of
the mountain sit down and say we've done
it everything's perfect and I just don't
think that exists it's called Heaven
yeah yeah right for the time being on
this planet there's Cycles there's
changes there's Ebbs there's flows
there's Yin there's Yang whatever you
want to call it there's a equal and
opposite reactions which means you're
never going to be able to sit down and
just be like my job is done look at
Fashion it just keeps it just keeps
coming back cyclical yeah yeah yeah and
and what's fascinating now too is when
people talk about uh communism they're
like all these Communists in the
government and I'm like there's
something else Communists were 100 years
ago they had they had a specific
ideology relevant to their time we're
looking at something else call it
techno-communism I don't know techno
Corporal corporate communism I don't
know it needs a new word yeah you know
we can't just look back and feel like
hey they're similar so we're gonna use
the same name you know times change man
some some new authoritarian ideology is
emerging on the turn of the century and
uh
it's gonna clash with some other
authoritarian ideology so here you go
all right droid control ship says hey
Tim I've been watching your coverage for
a short while can you spell that quote
you keep saying Biden said
because I was saying true enough I was
before I was saying true and Nana I
think there's an extra in in there true
no not a bit of pressure and batacav
Care better calf care watch them add
that to the dictionary like if I didn't
Gaff those are real words true true
is an actual word yeah Joe Biden's just
much smarter than his vocabulary words
it's a Scranton word yeah dude imagine
playing Scrabble with Joe Biden that's
got to be a cartoon
Mark says Tim you don't believe Vlad
won't level a city intentionally please
don't insult the millions of Assyrians
like that wait wait wait you said I
don't believe Vlad won't I I I do
believe Vladimir Putin would I think
he's misunderstanding what you were
saying when when we were talking about
this going after the citizens earlier no
he won't just go after citizens but if
it's in that act of War that's what I
want to clarify right like I don't think
Putin is a comic book villain who's
sitting there and go and he goes you
know what let's waste Munitions blowing
up Regular People for no reason no I
think he's like blow up that shopping
mall because they're staging military
weapons there but sir that'll kill
civilians yeah well this is in a
military operation and this is what war
is yep so I saw damage right so I'll
clarify like yeah civilians are being
killed in the Collateral Damage I don't
think he's throwing his mustache sang we
must kill as many civilians as possible
I don't think he puts a lot of thought
in I mean truth be told I do think
Putin's probably trying to avoid because
anyone who's engaging in information
Warfare and manipulation knows
minimizing civilian casualties is
important but uh this idea that
everyone's a comic book villain look
even the most uh typically the most
self-interested egotistical person isn't
going to be like I'm gonna kill a bunch
of people you do have crazy people crazy
people again can gain control of
governments and maybe Putin's one of
them but you know I think some The
Simple Solution is no one is just
generally trying to kill civilians
so can you read uh random Eskimos pretty
funny yeah random Esco says Sheamus take
it from a Utah Mormon any and all
reasons to laugh at Mitt Romney is not
only valid but necessary and I just want
to say I completely agree I I completely
agree I thought it was a good reason to
laugh at him back then I just think it's
still a good reason to laugh at our
media now Russia is our number one
existential threat fluffer boy 2004 says
Will Smith gets mad when other men make
jokes about his wife but not when they
sleep with her that's correct
that whole thing was staged I think it
was so someone actually did this really
great analysis where they got high
resolution video and slowed it down and
it's really interesting because uh
Chris Rock doesn't defend himself leans
into it but no no he leans with the he's
he Swings with the hand like fight
choreography so maybe look I've walked
into a bunch of people and then I've
been like what would you do if someone
was about to hit you and I'll raise my
hand and what does everyone do they go
like this yeah your hands instinctively
go up Chris Rock had his hands behind
his back the whole time and he had it
and he was leaning forward Will Smith
did a a look at his hand when he's when
he's cranking it's a very weak slap yeah
he had that Ali training he knows how to
hit yeah that's right Will Smith has
been trained you ever see him be on set
with guns and stuff yeah the dude has
has so this weak slap where Chris Rock
goes with the hit and you get down here
if you're gonna smack somebody you try
to hit that ear right because that just
that'll put your lights out yeah I think
it was fake plus Will Smith laughing at
the joke plus he's grinning as he walked
away he's trying to smell it yep yeah
yeah I think it was staged because uh
now what's happening is uh Chris Rock's
ticket sales have gone up two-fold yeah
so more than two days than you had in a
month yeah plus the price like she said
went way up yup yup and people are like
why would they stage this and it's like
because the Oscars were sinking nope now
everybody's talked about that for two
days I know here we are people talking
about it
Curtis Fletcher says anyone else here
that India and China are dropping the
Petro dollar
uh I don't know about that just yet
there's probably conversations but that
would tell you if uh if that was the
news we'd lead with it and we would all
be like you'd see a wall of emergency
food behind me the moment these
countries dropped the Petro dollar which
may be coming yeah no joke because
that's when it's like ten dollars for a
gallon of milk 20 bucks a gallon all
that crazy stuff no matter how much
money you got it's not worth much I
think people don't realize that if these
countries drop the Petro dollar you want
to talk about expensive gas oh boy Whoa
man it's gonna be really bad yeah I
think this country would be ripped
ripped apart I you know
if Joe if if if the Petro dollar is
dropped whoever is President will be
blamed and it's gonna get brutal you're
gonna see you're gonna see 48 year old
like you know women out in the streets
some from the suburbs throwing garbage
cans because it's going to be bad you
know feed their kids yeah you think the
summer of 2020 was bad and granted you
know the media doesn't but if you're a
reasonable person who saw the summer of
2020 and said I don't like that I don't
want more of that oh my goodness if the
Petro dollar gets dropped
oh that's not gonna look like it was
anything I mean that that's going to
look like a small Skirmish and I have
talked to several media members who got
up and did what these cops did with the
mandates and they read their
teleprompter and they totally disagree
with it but to keep their job they read
the teleprompter
all right same crap we got this from s
thiemen he says 30-year Louisville KY
resident lmpd have a tough job and a
spineless mayor Fisher thank you officer
Mattingly for your service well thank
you appreciate it all right
all right what do we got Edmar says Tim
you don't see the big picture about the
war it's big map manipulating the map
Market Rand McNally is funding weapons
to Russia look it up on Wikipedia after
I tweet it for their citation
so they're like we need to issue new
maps so Russia needs to get even the
tiniest piece of Ukraine everybody's got
to buy it do you remember when when
Kamala said Russia is a big country
Ukraine's a small country I mean that
proves it she was holding her Rand
McNally man that's right
Daniel muek says Bach ladies and
gentlemen um I also want to let you guys
know that if you go to chicken City on
YouTube and give five dollar streets
come down we have a little automatic
treat dispenser chickens are sleeping so
I don't know if it works at night but we
are getting ready to launch chicken
party we've already made the song that
you can party song you may have heard it
I've heard it uh and the idea is we're
going to create a a meter that once it
fills all the way up it reaches a
hundred dollars it triggers the chicken
party and then we're gonna have disco
lights and it plays a dance song yeah
yeah now have you have you tried it does
it work the chickens up at all like you
get them excited they get like startled
yeah because it the first noise is a
rooster crow and the speaker and the
roosters are like what and then ice
cream chicken party and then it plays
this song I took this song uh and then
edited it with chicken chickens blocking
to the beat and roosters crowings like
dance music for the chickens but uh so
I'm hoping we have that up soon it's all
duct tape
we've got to use a bunch of different
systems like if this then that in
streamlabs to create a way to track
super chats in a meter and then
ultimately trigger a sound triggering
the sound is the hardest part because
how do you get a speaker to play a sound
it's it's not so it's it's not the
easiest thing there might be some some
coding we might have to do into it but
we've found some duct tape methods of
getting it to to to play
probably just like well I'll leave that
we we think we have it and hopefully in
the next day or so you will have the
opportunity to give money to support a
chicken party every day and have the
dance music play for the chickens
because that's the important thing
that's that's what we do it's very
important makes life easier
all right let's grab some uh we got
Nesquik says based guest tonight well
there you go thank you
people news today says delete laws is
fighting corrupt cops please help I
don't know who that is but look them up
I like the idea so
all right let's see
Aimbot says John if I set up a meeting
to speak one-on-one to Donovan Mitchell
would you take it
absolutely I love Donovan Mitchell who's
Donovan Mitchell he played for
Louisville he plays for the Jazz now oh
okay great player All-Star
would Donovan Mitchell though yeah I
don't know he's he's not anti-police
because he would he just uh supported uh
retired lmpd guy who's running for
Sheriff
um he did have my case wrong Donovan if
you're listening uh he had my case wrong
on the Brianna thing same one murdered
her everybody did put her yeah and this
is can I go back back to this real quick
so when my kids I've got adult kids who
you know they went to public school and
they had a very diverse friendships
friendship groups and
um they came to me when this first
started they're like oh this person said
this I can't believe it they're mad and
I'm befriending them and I'll never talk
to me I went whoa whoa whoa wait a
minute don't do all that I said just sit
back we're taught at a young age to
believe the media right where do we get
our info from the media the news
that's all they're getting they're not
getting any pushback from anybody so
naturally if I didn't know the case I
would have believed it for for eight
months nothing was said and opposed to
all the lies so
naturally if somebody's lying about you
what do people do they defend themselves
right right and when when that's not
happening you assume well I guess then
what they're saying is true yeah and so
I told them just wait till the truth
comes out and then if they still feel
that way then you can cut their
friendship off but just pump the brakes
all right we got a really important one
here from Stephen Richards with a with a
big Super Chat he says a cab and then
Pig and clown emojis
I like pigs
I like donuts too you forgot that one oh
yeah acab stands for all cops are
bastards oh oh yep but I know my mom and
dad so it's cool but Steven gave us
forty dollars for that Super Chat and uh
and I think I think as much as it
doesn't really Express all that much of
a idea that we can contemplate I do like
reading uh uh you know contrarian
thought or or arguments or you know
opposition opinion so uh you know we'll
take it by all means Stephen I'm gonna
give you a hint though that really
doesn't offend cops anymore we're it's
so numb to it it's just it's a waste
your 40 money 40 bucks but Tim
appreciate it no no it's not give me
your Tim appreciates
I found my book it's only 30. there you
go it's cheaper they're not saying it
for you to offend you they're saying it
to make sure everybody knows that they
think cops are bad right oh cool yeah
I'm like you I think I think cops are
bad oh okay love you Steve I certainly
you know like saying abolish the police
all the time because of the coveted
stuff that's for sure but but I also
want to stress that you know I've I've
like my point on that is it's kind of a
shock statement that is not completely
untrue my position is mostly just we
need serious reforms whatever you want
to call it but if if we're at the point
where we're looking to we're looking at
woke leftist cops at that point I'm like
let's abolish him before it gets to that
point yeah I'm with you I don't know if
you saw that specifically this point was
because in Seattle cops arrested a guy
who was being attacked by antifa and
then apologized to antifa yeah yeah but
when the good cops all quit
who's left yeah well I've been warning
people of that you know you keep chasing
the good ones off you're going to be
back in the 80s like New Orleans and
Detroit where you have so much
corruption we're all screwed when you
outlaw police Only The Outlaws will be
police there you go I don't know how
that makes sense but all right Caleb W
says Tim you keep mentioning David
Pacman in the same space as yourself
Crowder Kim Iverson and another legit
independent personalities don't demean
yourself to that dude don't demean
yourself to that dude is a radical
leftist that lies as much as CNN I've
sent you articles about UFC
um I think uh
I don't know what David's deal is I I
I've I've known him for a really long
time there were a few stories that I
because I've seen I watched his content
periodically he got wrong and I talked
to him on Facebook and I sent him like
hey check this out I think you missed
this story because this is a correction
and he just ignores it but then he
certainly you know like so I know he
gets it like I know he sees me being
like here's an article from The New York
Times showing that the thing you just
put out was wrong and he just doesn't
say anything so you know that being said
I don't expect everyone to be correct
and um I encourage people to watch
everyone so when I mentioned David
Pacman it's not it's basically because
I'm not going to sit here and pretend to
be the Arbiter of Truth and morality and
to be better or smarter than anyone I'm
gonna say you go watch his content and
like Caleb maybe you'll come to that
conclusion and be like wow okay so this
this guy's not good or maybe you'll be
like wow David made a good point Tim was
wrong I think I I think I have faith in
your intelligence and you guys going and
watching other channels is important for
you to develop resilience to the lies
and the manipulations
I'm not here to tell anybody how to live
their lives to a certain degree
um obviously I have my opinions on
morality and ethics but ultimately I
think when it comes to the truth that
motivates the actions
um I think you should have a lot of you
know responsibility I'll put it this way
I can certainly say I think people
should be standing up for themselves
doing this if they want these things but
that is in the sense of if you tell me
you want freedom if you tell me you want
your kids to be safe I will tell you my
opinion on what I think would work for
you and that is standing up for what you
believe in because it'll make everyone's
lives better but truth be told
you do you do all me I don't want to be
responsible for your life you know so so
for you know by all means be critical of
me and whenever you feel like it and I I
respect and expect it
all right DJ Madero says Tim Star Trek
Enterprise in a mirror Darkly good
episode it's a great episode uh a Star
Trek it has great an episode as Star
Trek's DS9 in the pale Moonlight you've
seen it yeah yeah in a mirror Darkly
it's a good episode um it's one of the
few I could remember by episode title
yeah it was decent because Enterprise
was not a very good series I watched it
as a kid and I loved it because I was a
kid and then I remember revisiting it
when I was probably 14 years old or so
and going this show isn't that good but
but that episode I very much enjoyed so
I don't want to spoil too much just for
the quick yeah so so start the point of
Star Trek Enterprise is it takes place
before it's a prequel series and so what
happens is they find a portal to like a
Mirror Universe which is just a
basically identical to theirs but a
little further in the future and they
find the Starship which is the same
class as the original Star Trek series
so it's like it looks like the same set
from the 60s and the same ship yeah it's
it's it's a good episode cool Jeffrey
faff says why would CNN poll 10-minute
news Clips off YouTube because they want
you to go and watch on CNN plus where
you pay three bucks a month oh yeah oh
yeah that's right yeah forgot about that
so it's it's so what we did was we
didn't take our Clips off YouTube we
just created a segment for the website
CNN has done that as well they've
created like Jake tapper's book club and
you know other ridiculous shows but
they're trying to compete in the space
I'll tell you take a look at
Netflix Netflix had Marvel shows where
are those shows now they're on Disney
plus because Disney was like why are we
giving our shows to Netflix we can make
our own we can make our own streaming
service
YouTube in 2012 one of the one of the
top YouTube people like I know I've
known a lot of people I have friends at
Google told me that they're competing
with Netflix and that's their goal
what's going to happen now when all of
these big networks that put content on
YouTube say we're doing our own
streaming service they're going to be
like put the promos on YouTube for
posting on Twitter and then put the real
stuff on our platform where we can make
money that means these big networks are
going to pull off YouTube even the small
ones because you know we're certainly
looking at uh I would rather have our
own website and I can tell you this
YouTube
we about a third of all of our ad
Revenue that goes to YouTube uh that
comes through YouTube goes to YouTube
what if I just made my own website took
100 of the ad revenue and then paid 35
to Market myself instead of giving it to
Google how do I even know that they're
marketing me effectively based on the
amount of money they're taking I don't
so YouTube certainly made an incentive
for people to abandon the platform at
least in the next several years
all right let's let's grab some more
we'll just do a couple more because I I
didn't see I I wanted to grab some
specific questions to get some Nuance
but I think you know can I mention
something very quickly I'm seeing in the
non-paid super chats people are noticing
that I am differently colored than I was
two episodes ago or three episodes ago
so the camera was blue I looked like Joe
Rogan on CNN I want all of you to know
it was because of the tint of the camera
when it was funny because I had not been
on the several episodes prior to that
one and so people thought that I had
been sick and was recovering and that's
why it was blue but that is not the case
that's right
Mike Tapia says everyone in the chat
room type in Bok Bok for chicken City
I suppose yes Raymond g Stanley Jr says
guys watch Arcane on Netflix good stuff
well all right all right
Jeffrey faff says so you agree with me
it's promo clips now is that what it
already is because I wouldn't be
surprised if that that's kind of my
point but I don't know I could be wrong
uh all right ladies and gentlemen we're
gonna go and record this members only
podcast for all of our members head over
to timcast.com and join the movement yes
yeah well so what we're doing is we're
trying to expand we're trying to make
culture very much like the daily wire is
doing our intent is to expand as much as
we can
the challenge is I am but one one humble
man trying to to do this which means
we've got to figure out strategic ways
of expansion
um which means we gotta hire people
project managers producers and all this
stuff and it is it is difficult to
manage because uh we're certainly not
we're nowhere near as big as the daily
wire they're massive but we hope to get
to that point
I'm a big fan of what they're doing
culturally and with your support at
timcast.com we're going to be able to do
a lot more of this so we have plans for
events our mobile studio is current our
new mobile studio is currently being
built we are we're planning a trip out
to the Daily wire I believe soon to hang
out at their Studios and do some
collaborations and Bully Michael goals
that's right and bullying Michael
Knowles I suppose uh and play some music
with him but uh if you guys want to
support us you'll you'll get this
members only podcast coming up just
about 11 p.m so check it out you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast uh John
you want to shout anything out you got a
book you got social media yeah 12
seconds in the dark you can get it
anywhere you can buy books whether it be
Amazon Target Walmart online it's in
stores at Books and Noble and uh books
or Barnes and Noble and books a million
um so yeah get the book any social media
it's at sergeantmattingly at
sgtmattingly that's uh anywhere from
Facebook Twitter Instagram all that
right on I'm Seamus Coughlin I run a
YouTube channel called Freedom Tunes we
release an animated cartoon every single
week sometimes twice a week we're doing
a tune this week on the um the issue of
men competing in women's sports because
they've called themselves women and sort
of this like berry milk toast response
you get from a lot of conservatives who
won't even go as far as to say that so
check it out I think you guys will enjoy
it go over there and subscribe love you
all thanks for tuning in thank you guys
all for tuning in on this insightful
evening you guys may follow me on
Twitter at sour patchless and
onminds.com I also have what is kind of
like a link tree it's sourpatch lids.me
and that has all my social media guys
can check it out there make sure you
head over in the meantime to youtube.com
chicken City And subscribe right now
what you'll see is the IR camera showing
sleeping chickens but throughout the day
it's quite fun and and truth be told a
lot of people are saying we have we have
like 17 500 subscribers on this channel
in like three weeks because people
people here's here's the truth when
people are at work and they're just like
in the office or whatever putting it on
the background you hear like woodpeckers
and you hear like birds tweeting and
you'll hear like a train horn and then
you'll hear Sasquatch then you'll hear
me screaming at the chickens you'll hear
my conversations as I'm outside the door
yeah it's great but but but but people
like the background nature sounds which
is really what makes chicken City work
and then also the chickens are hilarious
you can give them treats and they run
around doing chicken stuff so they're
quite silly things and the best part is
they they just poop where they walk
they'll just literally walk and then
just so anyway thanks for hanging out
everybody
that's right
A Little Joe Biden's walking around yeah
they do when the when the rooster jumps
in the back of the hands they do call it
the old Biden
because the rooster bites the neck of
the hen and it looks like like he's
buried in it sniffing like he's got his
head you know like he did that one time
anyway one time that way
come on now yes yes we must be fair head
over to timcast.com we'll see you all
over there in a little bit thanks for
hanging out bye guys